The Babylon bee has been suspended from
Twitter because they made a satirical
article labeling a transgender male as
man of the year after USA Today said
this individual was woman of the year
the CEO of Babylon B is refusing to
delete the Tweet thus it remains up
creating a very strange circumstance
where Twitter has the power to remove
the Tweet they say is offensive but they
won't do it there's an interesting
question here we'll we'll talk about why
doesn't Twitter just say it violates the
rules and it should leave it should not
be here why are they saying you have to
be the one to take it down that I think
is interesting because I wonder how that
will play into the law if they find
something objectionable but they won't
take it down when this question's there
so we'll talk about that we also have
the story about this NCAA female swimmer
who is now speaking out against
transgender male swimmer Leah Thomas
though what I find interesting here is
that this individual individual chose to
support and compete Heat against Leah
Thomas and is only complaining after
losing so there's a lot of interesting
uh cultural stories we have now
especially Forbes has written a hit
piece on Dave Rubin because Dave Rubin
is having his discussion with
conservatives about being a gay married
man with kids and of course we will talk
a lot about what's happening in New York
seems to be falling apart revenues are
not coming back unemployment is still
really bad crime is through the roof
there's like a serial killer and so we
can talk about all of that stuff as well
as right to repair and what's going on
with technology and economics and
joining us to discuss all that is Louis
Rosman
thank you for having me on do you want
to introduce yourself yeah sure my name
is Louis Rossman I run a repair shop in
New York City and I do videos showing
people how to fix things and I show them
all the the barriers that get in the way
of people being able to fix their stuff
and I just try to get people a little
bit more invested in what we do by
showing them what happens behind the
scenes I want people to kind of be in uh
actually want people like us to be able
to be our do our jobs rather than just
think that where these shade tree
mechanics where you don't really
understand how we operate who they have
no investment in cool cool absolutely we
got some censorship stories too so we
can talk a lot about the tech elements
there as well we got Ian what's up
everybody Luke roodkowski uh sent Tim a
beautiful birthday gift of this hat that
I'm wearing and this golden beanie which
I haven't seen on Tim yet we'll see if
we can get that on them tonight and also
we've received these two dice uh this
Hadith 100 and 20 120-sided die and a
48-sided die I don't think they actually
have 120 it's two different you want red
or green
it's two different weirdly numbered
someone was like these are the only dice
you'll ever need because you can like
decipher you can roll the 120-sided one
and get like act as if it's a d10 act if
it's if it's a D20 I don't even looked
into it yet interesting but thanks for
sending them they're pretty cool
if you didn't get that yet and I'm also
here I'm seeing a lot of excitement in
the chat for Lewis really excited to
have him and hear what he has to say yes
before we get started we have an amazing
sponsor tonight uh we're sponsored by
the daily Wire yeah you can check out
their new series fighting the enemy
Within China by clicking the link in the
description below now normally I have
like a snazzy URL for you but this one
is utm.io uen one capital D or just
click the link in the description in the
description below use the promo code Tim
pool and you'll get 25 off of your
membership the daily wire to watch the
Enemy Within and the daily wire says
what if here's our tagline What if
everything we think we know about our
leaders or society and our relationships
with the rest of the world is wrong
acclaimed journalist expert in National
threats and writer of the plot against
the president Lee Smith uncovers a
political coup orchestrated by America's
political corporate and media Elites to
generate wealth power and Prestige at
the expense of the safety and freedoms
of the American people right now look at
their five episodes one on fauci Biden
the education system Sports and
Hollywood and truth be told a lot of
these are deep dives into many of the
subjects that we talk about so when we
got were the daily wires interested in
having us do a sponsored spot for them I
was like yeah absolutely this sounds
fantastic so again the link is in the
description below use promo code Tim
pool for 25 off your membership daily
wire and uh thank you daily wire for
sponsoring this episode of timcast IRL
but also don't forget go to timcast.com
and become a member if you want to
support our work directly as a member
you'll get access to exclusive podcasts
from this show that go up Monday through
Thursday at 8 pm I'm sorry 11 p.m this
show is live at 8pm and we will have one
of those episodes up for you later
tonight so you don't want to miss it
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
right now take that URL post it wherever
you can it's the most powerful way to
help support the work we do and let's
read that first story and talk about the
Babylon bee there's a lot here that I
find interesting this is a story we have
from timcast.com Babylon be locked out
of Twitter for Man of the Year satire
quote if the cost of telling the truth
is the loss of our Twitter account then
so be it said the CEO of the
christian-based satire news site so they
received a notification from Twitter
saying that their tweet has violated
their rules against promoting violence
threatening harassing uh other people in
the basis of race ethnicity national
origin sexual orientation gender gender
identity religious affiliation age
disability or serious disease they said
you can start your countdown and
continue to Twitter to Twitter so it
says once you delete the content that
violates our rules one tweet if you
think we've made a mistake contact us so
the CEO is saying he won't be taking it
down this is the post in question or
this is one of them it says the Babylon
bees man of the year is Rachel Levine of
course Rachel Levine is a trans woman
hence the the joke they were making
Twitter says this violated the rules so
there's something interesting here in
that one I think we can we can discuss
uh the CEO's unwillingness to take down
the post he's saying we're not going to
do it but also it's curious that Twitter
under uh section 230 which grants this
immunity to these Tech platforms it says
that you can remove content that you
find to be objectionable or you know
lewd or lascivious or whatever in this
instance and actually it should be told
this is this is typically how Twitter
does it they make you remove it so right
now this is where it's interesting Seth
Dillon has said the Tweet they say
Breaks the Rules is still up available
to be retweeted and seen by everyone and
it's going viral as people keep
retweeting it why would he take that
tweet down if he believes in it and why
wouldn't Twitter take it down if they
think it's wrong that's that's what I
find fascinating about the story other
than
there's the whole culture War aspect of
one perspective is allowed in one
perspective isn't but I'm curious if you
guys have anything it feels like a
parent making a kid clean up their own
mess as punishment
that's kind of Adventure because it's
not just saying we don't like what you
said it's also almost like a form of
humiliation because they're like you
also have to take it down it's not
enough that you be punished for this you
have to do it yourself like one of those
uh those what are they those classes
where they get you to say something you
don't believe until you start to believe
it the struggle session yeah like a
struggle session yeah apparently they're
doing that in prisons I didn't I don't
like this because
the the terms say if it promotes
violence against threatens or harasses
now this tweet does not promote violence
against anyone or threaten anyone but
you could say that it's a harassment
thing I don't think I think this is an
abuse of the word harassment for the
terms like it's a one-off tweet it's a
public figure uh I don't see any kind of
of consistent harassment for a claim and
and the guy can always block it anyway
so I I this is I just feel like it's so
heavy-handed I think it depends on your
definition of harassment I mean if if
you're a trans person is being
misgendered the same way as if I call
you uh I don't know you know bad word
for female genitalia or something you
know there's a if you're if I'm if I'm
using it and I'm saying something that
you feel is insulting is that harassment
but then again if that's the rule the
reason I deleted Twitter is because
that's literally all it is yeah this is
the first time in a long time I thought
I might actually just delete my nah I
deleted mine three years ago because
pretty much like it's just all that
non-stop all day long just yeah we were
talking about on the show like last week
that Twitter only exists to emotionally
destroy people yeah I mean you have when
you have it back when you you had only
140 characters to express something it
rewards a negative impulsivity in the
worst possible way and when I started
doing it that's when I deleted it I
started on my Twitter account 2008. um
and I I'll make YouTube videos oh 607
and I was like text is the devil do not
rely on text for communication verbal
communication is how we get along but
this text is and people like Ian you're
such an idiot text is fine man Twitter's
cool and then all these people start
tweeting and now you see the age of
miscommunication and there's a reason
for it is because people are etching
markings on a wall and expecting someone
else to know what they meant you know
Twitter is the worst it's pretty bad it
brings out the worst in people yeah and
like for me this I I would say okay you
should be allowed to make a joke
whatever but at the same time I look at
it and I go what am I gaining from
making that joke you know like I believe
in the right to be able to say something
like that but I just I wouldn't use it
if it's just gonna piss a bunch of
people off and I don't gain anything
from calling this person a man versus a
woman or whatever well I'll say I think
the The Babylon B is a Christian site
they have a perspective right yeah it's
also meant for humor and it's a satire
so they're going to say things that a
[ __ ] post that are gonna people right
right I mean comedy is offensive or at
least it used to be supposed to I don't
know what left-wing comedy is right now
there's this there's this YouTuber guy
and he um someone posted this in
response to Seth Dillon he's the CEO and
it was like why conservative comedy
isn't funny and it's just like a weird
thing to claim to like it's look I
understand the left is gonna pile on
this dude who wrote why conservative
comments isn't funny like they're gonna
they're gonna go and comment be like we
know we know it's so true conservative
comments and comedy isn't funny and I'm
just like yo it's subjective I've never
watched liberal versus conservative
commentary like when you when you look
at let's say Bill Bill Burr I think
would be more left in the Mala people
here what you have when you listen to
his 2012 special on Gold Digging [ __ ]
and beating women I mean would that come
out in 2022 no no no no
I'm surprised he hasn't gotten his head
chopped off for doing that I want every
now and then I'll watch that and just
like laugh hysterically
I don't understand the idea of like what
conservative comedy is
you know that's the weirdest thing that
the response from the left is like
you're not funny so it's not a joke I
think you're talking about Greg gutfield
versus uh what's the other guy like Seth
Meyers or something like that but that
stuff's not funny to me I don't enjoy it
either I mean but but I I don't
ideologically possess comedy sucks in my
opinion yes I I not necessarily it
depends if it speaks to your ideology
you're gonna enjoy it that so that's why
I say it's subjective when there there
was a vice special I saw where it was a
transgender comedian and they were
explaining how to do comedy properly you
make fun of yourself that we're not
hurting anybody and there's no
oppression and it was a bunch of people
in the audience and the person on stage
was like a tall skinny trans woman who
was constantly talking about how awful
they were to themselves and the audience
was laughing like no one's getting hurt
because they're making the joke about
themselves they seem to enjoy it I'm
just like I mean I'm not gonna rag on
somebody look if you want to make a
video game or a movie or a show and you
want to go and you enjoy it like man go
do your thing I got nothing to do with
it if I want to watch Dave Chappelle
don't get him canceled from Netflix
because you don't like it like you're
offended by it so you know Gutfeld I
think Gutfeld on Fox is more like a
observational humor but not I wouldn't
put comedy first it's like a it's a
political commentary show with snark
which makes you laugh some depending on
on his audience you know it's one of the
biggest shows Seth Meyers does the same
for the left maybe you want to argue
that they're only laughing with the left
like they're being told to laugh or
whatever I'll look if people want to
watch it and they get millions of views
they do same with Colbert I I had an
issue a couple nights ago I was watching
like the epic fails compilations on
YouTube you ever watched those where
he's just like epic fails and you see
people falling down and slipping on ice
and like tumbling into the ocean and
stuff and I was laughing but it wasn't
comedy that wasn't comedy it's people
getting hurt and people falling down but
I was laughing so I was laughing at
something that wasn't comedy it's
possible that what people consider
comedy is actually not it might
something or something that's funny
isn't necessarily comedy I was I
remember when I was little I was
watching I think it was America's
Funniest Home Videos oh yeah I think it
was Bob Saget and uh maybe I'm
misremembering this because it's been
like 30 years or something but it was a
guy skiing and he trips and starts
tumbling down the mountain and and Bob
Saget was going like nope
like like whoopsie fallen and I'm like
thinking to myself I'm like is that man
very hurt I'm confused like what's
happening and it was something like that
maybe maybe I'm you know remembering it
too harshly because I was like a little
kid so I think that when people make fun
of themselves in comedy it's kind of
like that you're laughing because you
see someone hurting themself in front of
you but it's not funny it's not well
it's funny but it's not comedy at least
in my opinion I don't like that
self-depreciating stuff I get I mean
it's all right Rodney Dangerfield did it
okay Bill Burr was all right with it but
Dangerfield rip on his wife too so he
like no one was sacred yo I've been I've
been thinking about like the the the
pronouncement to the the
the culture war is just getting so
insane that when we say there's no
middle ground there's literally like
we're well beyond any kind of reasonable
logic so you know I'm gonna bring it up
because I I really want to but I had
this tweet last like this weekend about
going to a diner yeah it was like Friday
or something yeah where I was like I
went to a diner with my girlfriend and
we were we were they told us 20 they
said it was a 20 minute wait
and then uh they seated other people
before us so I complained and left and
like the point of my tweet was one I'm
kind of irritable you know so that's
like a not a positive statement about
myself but that you know it serves me
well in my work and business that I
don't tolerate any kind of you know
impedance so if they're like oops we
seated someone else before you I'll just
back I'll go somewhere else like I got
no issue I'm not going to bother I'm not
gonna I'm Gonna Leave the weirdest thing
is how this became a culture War issue
it became political like on Twitter I
read it the right can't meme it's like a
subreddit where they just make fun of
like right-wing people they screen
grabbed it and they were like
I I it was just like making fun of me
for no reason on an inane tweet having
nothing to do with politics and that's
what I bring I want to bring that up
because you mentioned well for one I
wanted to bring it up but also you
mentioned how it's just like negative
impulses on Twitter and I'm like I
didn't I didn't talk smack about anybody
like I I typically I I I was about to
tweet about AOC last week and it was
like nasty and so I like toned it way
down like I want to make my point but I
shouldn't insult her or anything like I
I can I can you know criticize her
without just being stupid and childish
but man I think I I think you nailed it
when you said it's just it drives
negative impulses I also think as we
mentioned before it exists just to
emotionally destroy people the one there
you ever disagree with you is where you
said that there's no middle ground in
the culture War it's either here or here
the middle ground is not on there and
the tablet it's out there like every
time I go outside and I talk to somebody
in a line at a grocery store it was a
date I was on two weeks ago with
somebody who I thought absolutely
horribly like hate me over with their
position they said you know like she
actually asked me she's a black because
she's more left than I am she's what do
you think of BLM and I said you're okay
this is going to be fun my white story
that was like there with the activating
a 400 watt air horn on my phone every
time I heard somebody banging on the
door uh June 2020. and it was actually a
very very reasonable conversation I
heard where she was coming from she
heard where I was coming from that
doesn't happen on Twitter that doesn't
happen oh for sure but like this happens
at the line at the grocery store this
happens at the gym this happens at you
know martial arts class it happens
almost everywhere it just doesn't happen
on the internet because there's
something about how people act when
they're behind a screen that changes
their entire perspective and I think the
fact that all the political
conversations that we're having now
versus 20 or 30 or 40 50 years ago are
not in person where there's always that
thought of you know I could get punched
in the face exactly wasn't it Mike Tyson
yeah yeah that model that modifies
people and for the last two months I
have spent way more time uh avoiding my
YouTube comment section avoiding social
media and actually engaging with people
in reality or you know sitting next to
them at a steakhouse or a bar and
talking and it's it's a radically
different world there isn't Middle
Ground like most people are in that
middle ground that's just they're out
there they're not on the internet wow
well so the problem is before you even
get a chance to have that middle ground
at that conversation
the internet is sort of gaining more and
more ground the other thing more and
more control you don't know like if you
see somebody's Facebook post where they
say all this other stuff it may kind of
aggravate you already because like wait
I don't agree with you here this that
and the other and you're immediately
going to be arguing instead of just
asking questions so what do you think of
this and then I give my perspective you
give yours you have kind of a back and
forth you're already aggravated when you
read somebody who's used their limited
140 characters to come up with the most
uh douchey way to say that they don't
like something yeah or a way to like
there was this one article I read
recently it was about the
it was about lawn signs and it was
something on the lawn sign you know in
this household we believe that women's
rights are everybody's rights uh you
know no person is illegal this that and
the other and it's like there's not real
like that that sign is an Fu Republican
sign it's not an actual I believe in all
this and it also doesn't necessarily
invite discussion the same way that the
whole uh you know like you owe me gas
money sign with like Biden with neck
with like uh I did that an azizian ping
uh you uniform and all that that's that
that Meme culture and all that that
doesn't open you to a discussion the
same way that just oh you know you're
sitting next to somebody that's not the
intent the intent is to create a
perception of majority so the Biden
stickers the goal of that is so that
regular people will see Biden being made
fun of and not want to be in the out
group so if they're someone who doesn't
follow politics and they go to a gas
station and they keep seeing the Biden
stickers well then they're more likely
to be like oh yeah yeah I think I think
Biden's dumb like because the perception
is if most people follow this you don't
want to be in the out group because the
out group is dangerous you lose access
to resources and humans have that
natural survival Instinct the same thing
is true for putting flags on their porch
or putting that sign they want everyone
to see the signs and so that's one of
the reasons I say there's no middle
ground there is you know like you said
outside for for the average person but
what we're seeing more and more
like the reason I brought this up is
that the conversations around politics
have become completely inane like we're
seeing more and more people being made
fun of for things that aren't even
political or conversations emerging on
things that aren't even political or
don't need to be I think everybody is on
edge to the point where they're just
waiting for the smallest thing to tick
them off to lose it yeah everybody is
very very on edge and walking just like
vibrating with rage well I think one of
the issues is that you have people who
it's an addiction it's a drug addiction
it's it's you want those hits you want
those clicks and you're trying to find a
way to get that satisfaction so you want
that tweet that's going to get a
thousand retweets or whatever so you
have a lot of people on social media who
are constantly one-upping each other
taking it one step further left and
right because
they want people to react they want
people to share they won't be able to
respond and there's no point where
someone just like people need to start
toning things down I I certainly think
that there are
I I look my perspective and my bias is
fairly obvious on this one there's a
reason why I think in polling moderate
voters and Republicans tend to agree on
a lot of issues and Democrats are
completely in the out group relative to
those two groups or I should say the
Democrats are isolated in their beliefs
Independents and Republicans overlap
massively on tons of issues and I think
it's because there's something just
generally tribalist and cultish of the
modern mainstream left and the things
they're pursuing you can get story after
story that turns out to be false and
they just end up believing it you get
illogical uh statements like only white
people can be racist and Candace Owens
is a white supremacist things like that
that don't seem to make sense I think
economically a lot of people wind up
leaning a little more left but
culturally they wind up leaning right
because they think that type of stuff is
crazy when they hear that you know you
cannot be you cannot be racist if you're
here but you can be racist if you were
born this way like someone will hear
that and go what where I think that same
person would would probably prefer
Medicare for all to the Health Care
System we have now where you get it you
like you uh you know you fall off a bike
and then you have a five thousand dollar
bill when you that you for spending 45
minutes in a hospital that you weren't
even awake for like all right or or even
choose to go to sometimes but there's
way more overlap than people think like
when you read the internet you really
think that okay because I've heard you
say this one thing I now know what you
think about these other 42 things but
then when you actually go out in the
real world you realize that it's not
like that it's not just the you know a
clipboard where there's like a check box
of 42 different things so so as much as
I would agree with you in a lot of this
um one of the challenges I see is that
the middle ground people aren't active
and so when we try and engage in things
they have jobs they have lives they have
things to do they're they're out there
doing everything this is what I
explained right for sure when we try to
do things however that we think are like
good politically I'll give you an
example a few years ago we put on an
event called ending violence racism and
authoritarianism and the keynote speaker
was a a very very famous black jazz
musician who de-radicalized members of
the clan far left groups threatened to
burn the theater down and then showed up
and protested at the the theater
canceled our contract within two weeks
so there was not even an opportunity to
have that middle ground conversation in
a public setting we ended up having to
move to a venue with half the seats we
were I think a hundred and some odd
people weren't able to attend because of
capacity issues so while there are
Middle Ground people who are working and
doing normal things if we want to change
things for the positive but we're being
shouted out and screamed at by the
squeaky wheel demanding the grease then
it is eliminating any Middle Ground
opportunities for conversations hyper
polarizing the conversation even in the
real world
hmm I can see if you're not allowed to
have an event how that would be
aggravating yeah yeah the naming of that
event I took issue with when we were I
was working with Bill we were kind of
formulating the idea of putting the
event together I didn't end up going to
that event actually but I didn't like
that it was ending violence as it was
like destroy evil as opposed to create
good like it's the phrasing what was the
argument from the people that wanted to
show to town uh I mean not taught to be
completely honest from any uh
if I was to make an assumption based on
what I know about these people they
don't have one other than they must
shout down any and all individuals who
hold civil libertarian views so these
were antifa critical race theorist types
and their their their whole attitude is
just prevent the conversation from
happening what was the conversation that
you were looking to have that night
ending violence racism authoritarian
authoritarianism so we actually had some
what is the conversation they thought
you were having
that's that's the conversation they
thought we were having Daryl Davis is
very famous I've heard of him yeah
they don't look they don't look at our
event and see a mixture of different
voices across the political Spectrum in
the headline the headliner was this
famous black man who de-radicalized clan
members who got a standing ovation they
don't see that and say some ex-grand
wizard of the KKK or something and
there's a picture of him like oh no 200
clan members it's still happening
I saw a two-hour interview with him on
Rogue in a few years yeah he's just on
the last week with Bill yeah
you have a speaker like that we had a
mixture of some social justice activists
like left-wing individuals as well as
right-wing and libertarian individuals
and not a single white nationalist or
alter any of that it was like a
relatively like Centrist libertarian
slightly center-right to actual far
leftists speaking there with our
headliner getting a standing ovation
from the audience there's no way they
look at that and they say these are
white supremacists now that's what they
told the press and the Press
uncritically publishes it it then they
go to the venue and say you have a bunch
of white supremacists we want you to
cancel it apparently they threaten to
burn the theater down so the guy you
know he calls me and he's like shut it
down no business is going to want to be
associated with that that's the problem
and there's going to be very few that
are going to want to deal with the
aftermath after they've gotten your
money for one evening so so it sounds
like to go back to what you're saying
with the middle ground existing it
exists in small private underground
conversations that people can't find out
about I think it exists largely it's
just the people that were doing that are
the type of people who are going to
threaten to burn a theater down they're
not the majority of Middle Ground people
they're a very small minority that just
so happens to be the loudest and the
most active the people that actually are
are in the Middle Ground they they have
lives like you know when I have
conversations with legislators I'll
often tell them when they'll go you know
there are 14 lobbyists against right to
repair you know and one person here and
I'll go yeah they're on a farm they're
they're the reason that you have
something to eat they don't have time to
drive two hours and then sit here
waiting for three hours that they could
speak for three minutes that's not a
good use of their time no offense I'm
not trying to be mean to you but they
this is not what they do the middle
ground people people are out there
making sure that we have electricity and
food and water and computers and
everything else they don't have time for
this [ __ ] they don't have time to try to
burn a theater down you're right uh the
issue is they are the majority what
happens initially and I agree but what
happens initially is that corporations
and politicians only hear one voice they
hear the people who are the loudest and
they hear the people who are the most
obnoxious and the people who are the
most obnoxious are often the people that
don't have jobs don't have lives don't
care about their reputation and exactly
that threaten to do things like that and
so what these legislators do is they
assume if regular working-class people
won't speak up for this and won't have
my back when I speak up for them I won't
so we had we had a guy in here Terry
Schilling just last week who said he's
he runs an organizations basically the
NRA for families and he was explaining
how I believe was the governor of North
Carolina is that what he said I think so
there was a governor who said if you
know if you support a particular Bill
all of like these conservative groups
were like we will have your back and he
was like okay and then when it came to
the politics they all abandoned him and
so he was like the only thing I see then
is the is the left coming out and using
force and actually following through so
that's that the issue I see is moderates
don't really have advocates in my for
the most part because you know moderates
are moderate for a reason they're like
interested in hearing what you have to
say or they're undecided so you have you
know a variety of right a variety of
left and some Centrist in between and
there's a there's a conversation
happening that for the most part the
right is unwilling to stand up behind
and the left is absolutely willing to
stand up and yell about so you'll end up
seeing Amazon Walmart our Xbox all these
video game companies publishing
statements in support of black
statements in support of black lives
matter and left-wing politics then when
it comes to the vote you end up with the
2020 that looks very much like it just
did with the Joe Biden winning and now
you have all the politics that come
after it I think for the most part now
what's happened in this country has
become so irrefutable that regular
people are like I'm voting Republican
the the general ballot uh midterm
General ballot polling is favoring
Republicans by like at 5 30 it has a 2.4
and Real Clear Politics I said 3.7 which
is absurd because it's always Democrat
up so now that's inverted they're
expecting it's going to be like a
crushing defeat for Democrats ultimately
I don't think that'll solve anything but
the issue then becomes if regular people
don't really pay attention because
they're too busy with their lives then
all that really ends up happening is
they'll say okay I'm not going to vote
for the Democrat this time I'll vote for
the Republican but the Republican is
just Democrat light it's going to be the
exact same policies the exact same play
the exact same corporatism or at the
very least they'll say you know we're
going to pause things for here and then
once Democrats get reelected they kick
things back into high gear and keep
moving forward
yeah
I'm uh I was just thinking about
about
creating the reality we want with our
words and how it's kind of disingenuous
to say like things are good if they're
not because it's like you're a realist
I'm kind of an idealist in in this in
this description anyway we're both kind
of moderate but
there is something to saying like re
this is the way reality is just
describing the way you want it to be
even if it's not yet so that people
start to believe it and start to work
towards it but it's also disingenuous
when because this is like the no truth
but Power like you can't just say that
something is and that it expect it to be
like but if you don't say that it is
it's never gonna happen so
I don't know man it's like you we need
we need like an ethical person to
manipulate people to the to the ends
that we need that it's going to be
better for the species nah see that's
the ends justifying the means but the
manipulation sounds like a yeah it does
sounds crazy but that's like what what
this is literally like having a
conversation or manipulating each other
with our words right now this is this is
like um what all of these big ngos and
you know Global uh uh you know
billionaire types Elites that's their
mentality I'm concerned that without a
leader manipulation there's an element
of negativity to it I don't think you're
doing it with a negative intentional
manipulating this hat I'm holding it I'm
moving it around manipulating it yeah
you're talking about controlling them
into doing things you want them they're
hugging your wife you're manipulating
her body you're manipulating her but
it's not a negative sense you know it
can be moderate it can even be good if
you're pulling someone out of a burning
fire you're manipulating them away from
the fire this is a justification for
authoritarianism well the thing is
without a leader I'm afraid that the the
the good U.S Constitution is going to
get scrubbed and burned
yeah man you know what they're rocking
the hard place the reality is that
people on the right be it you know and I
I mean this as the the colloquial
culture War right which includes Center
Centrist Libertarians and like
post-liberal types as well that they
don't stand up they don't go out they
almost never protest when conservatives
have gotten protest they get smeared and
and slammed by the media and labeled as
all the worst things in the world and so
for that reason I think there's a
there's a good chance that uh you know
another's a good chance but the left the
cultural left the the critical race
there has left all that they've gained a
lot of ground that being said I think if
you look at the polling coming out of
538 real clear politics is the
aggregates
the Republicans and the cultural right
have probably gained way more ground and
like you're saying most people you know
are probably feeling this way more in
the middle than than anything else at
least out there in the real world the
question is if the perception is that
the majority is on the left people will
be unwilling to speak out so let me let
me do this let me let me pull up this
story and give you a really good example
we have the story from foxnews.com VA
Tech swimmer rips NCAA transgender
participation policy feels like the
final spot was taken from him Reka
giorgi is am I pronouncing that wrong is
that guy orgy Yorkie because guy orji
sounds really bad yeah this is not good
he missed the cut for the I'm not trying
to do that I just I'm like I don't know
missed the cut for the consolation final
in the 500 free at the uh NCAA
championships so um this this swimmer uh
hit uh ranked 17th and thus was booted
out of the finals and then issued a
statement saying it's not fair because
Leah Thomas who won first place is a
biological male and that's why she got
bumped I'll tell you why I take issue
with this and it exemplifies what I was
just saying a moment ago I was
explaining how the the culture War right
doesn't stand up or better a better way
to put it is the middle the the the not
super political individuals who are just
working and living their lives don't
stand up
so you were saying just a moment ago
that you know regular people out there
in the world are probably closer to the
middle you know but they have lives and
jobs
the people at this in the in this uh
competition the NCAA uh women's league
apparently it's been reported privately
are all outraged that a biological male
is competing against biological females
but not a single one of them publicly
comes out and says I am upset about this
I do not feel it is right to have me
compete in this situation they could at
the very least say I am issuing a
protest to the fact that we are being
told we have to compete against a
biological male but I will swim they
could do that they won't even do that
and it it only after
the one person who just got bumped by
one slot loses do they come out and say
this is unfair here's why I find this
fascinating where is the person who got
18th why aren't they complaining and
speaking up oh because it didn't matter
they would not have one whether if Leia
Thomas was removed they'd be 17th they
still would not have made the finals why
isn't the person who's in 16th
complaining they made the finals what do
they care right the person who got 17th
was bumped by one space and they've got
a scapegoat for what's upsetting them
now if people in the middle actually did
care about this and apparently like look
behind the scenes a letter was issued
parents have been complaining if they if
they don't speak up and stand up for it
they actually believe in and are worried
about then they're just going to lose
and
what am I supposed to do just assume
their feelings and speak up for them I
mean I will but this is the main issue
right now this is a left ideological
position that a biological male is
competing against females this Leah
Thomas is six foot four broad shoulders
much much larger than all of the other
men was actually I think ranked number
eight in the men's division now a lot of
people are posting a meme showing that
Leah Thomas was ranked for 62 or
whatever that was after hormone
replacement therapy knocked Leah Thomas
to the bottom of the rankings and then
everyone started saying look it's a
bottom ranked male actually
um before transitioning was actually one
of the top ranked males and now is the
number one female but my point is this
if you're in the middle
and you're not paying attention you're
not speaking up this is what this is
what's happening these people privately
are complaining about it okay well if I
know they're mad at least we consume
they are they're going to lose
everything these young women are not
going to win gold ever again and it's
their own faults for not standing up and
actually issuing a complaint about
what's going on so here's the issue I
have with people not standing up for
women's sports they specifically ask for
a women's division I remember learning
about Title IX in high school that was
quite a while ago but that's the point
and I remember thinking okay I think
it's cool that women have their own
division that they can compete in that
they're only competing against other
women awesome if you fought for
something like that you need to defend
it and women are highly agreeable I see
women just going along to get along but
I tweeted earlier and I firmly believe
that if women don't stand up against
this if women don't refuse to swim with
this
um fall swimmer they deserve to lose 100
they deserve they deserve to lose all
the time they deserve no more gold
medals ever they don't deserve their own
League because if you're not going to
stand up for what whoever came before
you fought for then you clearly don't
think it's important you don't think
you're your scholarship's important I I
gotta I gotta add many of the women in
this league have actually spoken up in
defensively at Thomas really yes 100 and
even in this woman uh Reka Georgie oh
yeah she actually stated in her
complaint I fully stand with and respect
Leah Thomas she's no different from the
rest of us who wake up every day and
train hard it's like okay
I I I think to be completely honest and
I mean this legitimately Recca is only
complaining because she lost and she got
bumped and she has a scapegoat I think
you're right and this is exactly a case
of women being too agreeable you can't
give someone a foothold like that you
can say I respect them as an athlete
fine but they should never compete
against other women but why are you why
are you assuming they're opposed if they
publicly say they're for Leah Thomas why
would anyone assume they're opposed to
it well they wrote the letter you know
they talk behind the scenes you know we
really don't like be in the locker room
with this guy and I'm it's it's it's
obvious that this makes him
uncomfortable and they know there's
something wrong but they're not saying I
will not swim with him so we'll operate
under that premise behind the scenes we
have seen letters issued by the parents
complaining saying their daughters are
upset and they feel like you know
they're being cheated or whatever okay
well the issue is if publicly they won't
fight for it
they lose it yeah so we're operating
assumption they're upset it's all
happening but these are the regular
people who are working or going to
school deep down many of them know
they're being slighted being wronged
they're upset but they won't do anything
about it so what do we do look to
Caitlyn Jenner one of the sages of our
time you're going to talk to anybody
about transgender in sports Caitlyn
Jenner is the person who used to be
Bruce Jenner biological male transition
Caitlin Bruce was an Olympic Athlete I
think he won gold medals so yeah he's
like super famous boxes yeah yeah of
course the father in um the Kardashians
now's transition Caitlyn Jenner and
speaks out against this not says I have
the balls to stand up for women and
girls in sports like yes
right now I retweeted it um she says
that she's not about to stand up for
transgender rice she's here to protect
women's sports that's the point and
transgender rights yeah you're gonna get
transgender rights but women in sports
and women's sports is a unique it needs
to be protected I think that Caitlyn is
a perfect person to speak out about this
because Caitlyn you used to compete at
the Olympic level and then transitioned
to try to be more effeminine so here
let's look at the Tweet oh my God
Caitlyn Jenner was responding to Pink
news who said Caitlyn Jenner launches
and another disgraceful attack on trans
athletes without a hint of irony and
Caitlyn Jenner said no I just had the
balls to stand up for women and girls in
sports
and I didn't believe that tweet was real
oh yeah and a bunch of other people were
responding to screenshots of it saying
there's no way that's real that's real
but it's real yeah yeah so so anyway
look I don't I don't know you know going
back to what we were saying before in
the previous conversation about um just
everything that's been going on in the
culture War if most people are upset
about what's happening and feel like
they're in the middle ground but none of
them actually speak up then it's just
going to get worse I would even say that
that's proof that they're Caitlyn Jenner
is part of the middle ground yeah oh
absolutely yeah yeah absolutely she
probably disagrees with somebody like
Ben Shapiro and the daily wire and
certain trans issues but she also
obviously disagrees with the idea of of
uh who's come you know biological
somebody was born as a biological man
competing with a biological woman in a
sport but I think I think the issue is
that um what we would refer to as the
right in the culture War incorporates
post-liberal all the way to to far right
actually so you have this massively
eclectic group of people with varying
different opinions Caitlyn Jenner would
absolutely be considered on the right uh
Blair white who's who's trans is
considered right-wing right
um you know who else Jimmy Dore they
call him a leftist with an asterisk
because they're like he he he's well
sure he's a socialist but you know he
just espouses right wing talking points
so he's right wing so so the issue is
what Caitlyn Jenner would be
I mean it is called right wing so
they're not part of the left-wing
argument in in this in in the cultural
debate the the middle ground if you're
actually talking about how people feel
the middle ground is right wing
so that's another reason why I would say
there's no middle because if you come
out and say like me for instance I say I
support Progressive taxes admittedly I
think it's a problem just to take money
give to the government but I think
income inequality is a huge problem I
think systemic racism is a problem I'm
pro-choice they would say I'm still
right-wing even if I hold those
positions where clearly
um social left you know right right now
I mean we'll get into the story in a
second about Dave Rubin and
conservatives but if I say things that
are clearly economically left and social
left doesn't matter because my view of
the world or my ideas on civil
libertarianism don't sync up with the
left they would say it's right wing so
then if if my positions are not in the
middle then what's the what's the middle
yeah it's all relative
yeah
no idea no it's I think it's intended to
be obfuscatively uh confusing
well the issue is that the left the far
left is controlling all the institutions
so in a perfect world we could just
ignore all of this and say well 99 of
people are in what would be considered
the middle by the far left they're not
really right they just don't agree with
the far left does it mean about National
Power there's a meme the political
Compass where the top authoritarian left
says the left and everything else is far
right yeah is this the left that
controls every institution or so or
would it be neoliberal kind of people
like would you consider somebody like
Sergey Brin you know or somebody you
know the the CEO of Apple or the CEO of
Google or the CEO of Facebook are those
leftists or those people who are more
neoliberal who will tweet the right
thing at certain times but never
actually stand by so the so the issue is
when we're speaking about at least when
we do you know it's hard to do we have
to Define our words
here on this show
the left includes leftists and
neoliberal establishment and the reason
the reason is that the leftists tend to
align with support or vote for the
neoliberals Biden being a good example
so I'll I'll say Contra points for
instance is a prominent trans woman and
leftist YouTuber but made a video saying
you have to vote for Joe Biden
that being the case you'll see many of
these people like uh on the left like
vosh we've had in the show will call me
a conservative he clearly sees himself
contrasted with me even though he comes
on the show and we like we agree on
certain things granted he's been accused
of harboring very abhorrent you know
views himself whatever what he believes
is is entirely unto himself the issue is
that
it's more like it's like what matters
most is tribe not principle or fact so I
can come out and be like I think Donald
Trump represents the worst of American
culture but I certainly think he was the
better choice to vote for whereas the
left is like we don't care about all of
the corruption we've complained about
three years ago with Hillary Clinton
we're going to vote for Joe Biden anyway
or they make up some reason to hate
Donald Trump or leftists who you know
agree with the mainstream media's
narratives even though they've been lied
to 800 times in the past 10 minutes so
it's at that point like you can you can
see the distinction between the spheres
of influence one there's a bunch of
different ways to define the different
factions but you know in the right you
have people who are skeptical and
Discerning of news and demanding of
facts and on the left you have the media
report at this time so it must be true
oh that was wrong but this one the media
reported so it must be true are they
because I've seen a lot of right-wing
Facebook people that I know and they
don't seem very Discerning of a lot of
the garbage that gets posted on Facebook
yeah I mean if we're talking about
regular Layman you're going to see a
mixed bag of people who believe random
nonsense I'll just get I get a lot of
news articles in my comments so somebody
say hey check this out look at this and
then I'll check out the article and I'll
say oh that's a lot of interesting stuff
that they didn't cite and then I'll
Google it and it'll just all be
displayed but I'll clarify too I
specifically mean like among the the
leaders of you know uh you know talking
sharing ideas writing articles you'll
see on the left they repeatedly fall for
every single hoax the right certainly
does fall for some you know we had this
conversation last week but I can go
through the whole list of every black
lives matter protest that turned out to
be a false narrative like Trayvon Martin
Michael Brown uh Ahmed Arbor is a really
good example just over and over and over
again then you can look at the Covington
kids you can look at Jesse Smith you can
look at Russia get Ukraine all of these
stories prove it to be false the laptop
being the most egregious the issue is
when you have leftists and neoliberals
either pretending to believe or
genuinely believing stories that keep
getting proven false I think Trayvon
Martin and Jesse Smollett would be
different categories altogether one is
an area of fun of some what disagreement
on how something should have gone and
the other was I just made this up well
no no no Trayvon Martin was the media
edited the 911 from George Zimmerman to
make it seem like oh okay that's what it
is you're talking about also where they
made George Zimmerman look whiter by
photoshopping him yeah so what I mean is
that people keep falling for me I
understand for that yeah the the
corporate press will put out a lie and
then one group of people just says
that's true and then six months later
they're like well it was wrong but this
story is true I remember seeing when
they when they edited the way that he uh
looked when they edited his his facial
color that was kind of aggravating well
they they edited the the 911 call where
the 911 operator asked his race they cut
that part out so it sounded like he was
just saying he's suspicious looking
because he's you know he's black but
what really happened was he says you
look suspicious and they said how tall
is he he's like five ten and what's he
wearing he's wearing a hoodie and what's
his race I think he's black they edited
all that out so uh Michael Brown hands
up don't shoot now you have don't say
gay just media live after media life
after media live and and these people
just keep believing it at a certain
point I have to say they're probably not
believing it they're probably just lying
the problem with doing things like that
that erodes people's trust is that it
they're willing to go to the other side
and the other side can lie to them as
much as they want because they have
gotten because they just don't like this
side as much as they do and it happens
people who just all of a sudden are like
my political belief is now you know been
swayed because I'm hearing an argument
from someone who's been honest to me
about these other issues once somebody's
honest to you about these things that
you've been lied to it's very easy for
that person to lie to you about
everything else and for you to be less
critical and then for the pendulum to
swing in the other direction and go back
and forth yeah so you know the way I see
it is at a certain point people will see
like 10 stories in the mainstream press
that are all lies and then they'll turn
to a conservative and say tell me the
truth and they'll say well you know
those things are lies right okay now
this was a truth you know here's the
truth here and they'll say okay I
believe you because I I have no I don't
know who else to trust right if you if
you're honest to me about these issues
you're probably honest about this one
and so you know ultimately therein lies
the big problem which is the middle
ground I guess the right are people who
just don't trust the establishment
anymore yeah one way to put it yeah it's
like the media reports and you're like I
don't believe it
you know I kind of see it a little bit
more as weak-minded people and
strong-minded people uh you get
weak-minded people on any any side
extreme leftist extreme right as people
that just buy the bull
and that's the matter not everyone's
always weak-minded sometimes
strong-minded people become weak-minded
because of bad diet not enough sleep
stress sometimes weak-minded people get
strong-minded because of adversity and
they they struggle through adversity but
that's that's more of a category as I
split these people look let's pull up
this smear oh boy Forbes publishes an
article titled Dave Rubin is being
rejected by his own audience all right
all right well a lot of people have
criticism criticisms of Dave Rubin but
um I don't think this headline actually
fits what is being accused of Dave Rubin
it's the weirdest it's clearly a lie and
this is once again the game being played
the story is I'll simplify and then
we'll go through it Dave Rubin and his
husband are having two children through
surrogacy
prominent Christian conservatives say I
disagree with gay marriage and I
disagree with birth through surrogacy
therefore you know we'll we'll issue
statements of criticism towards Dave
Rubin that's very very different from
saying that his own audience has turned
against him because like a handful of
public figures who are Christian
conservatives are having conversations
with him where they say they disagree
and they don't like his lifestyle you
know if his audience turned against him
you'd expect like he's losing millions
of subscribers or you know tens of
thousands he's getting disliked like
crazy and that's not happening so here
here's the point of this article in my
opinion they've not written an article
to inform anyone of anything they've
written an article to just rile up
people who already hate Dave Rubin so
they can be like haha I was right the
whole time Dave Robin's a bad person
there's there I I don't genuinely know
like if anything is to be gained by
media doing things like this and so you
know I'll do a throwback when you said
that Twitter is just you know negative
impulses I think that's where the
entirety of the media is at well if I
read forbes's own description of himself
the first reaction that I have to this
before I even care about the story is
they say Forbes is a global Media
Company focusing on business investment
technology entrepreneurship and
Leadership and like you're writing about
a dude that decided to have a kid while
he's gay with husband yeah that's right
slow news day I mean yeah why do I I
don't care I mean is why yeah maybe
maybe what we need there's a lot of
money to be made in making people think
the world is worse than it is the world
is more divided than it is and we hate
each other more than we do and I think
everybody's looking to get in on it as
much as humanly possible and I find it
disgusting not everybody but so enough
people are that it's raising an alarm
Bell I don't I I would say there are
certainly the grifters as we call them
who want to get in on it I wonder if
also people are genuinely just in that
world and it's making it worse and it's
making it more pronounced so the more
stories like this come out the more
people get riled up the more they talk
about about it I genuinely think there
are a lot of people on the left who
truly believe what they're saying and
every day they come out saying you know
the Republicans are worse than the Nazis
or whatever I think they really believe
it I think they justified in their own
minds I certainly think there are people
on the right who do the same to the left
however I think the tendency on the
right is they tend to know what the left
is thinking so they have a more balanced
view of what the culture War actually is
and the left just keeps one up
one-upping everything and getting more
and more absurd
yeah that's definitely true and I think
one of the things that I have observed
with the right is that people say oh um
well one of the things I've noticed at
the right is constantly more well-versed
in what the left thinks and the left is
and what the right thinks because we are
constantly exposed to what the left
believes because as I said earlier the
left is in charge of the institutions
especially journalism and that's why I
think that such a majority of Twitter is
so left-leaning is because most of them
are journalists how do you define that
though I mean when I hear somebody say
the left that could be almost anything
from Michael Bloomberg to vosh I mean
that's a very very large Spectrum it
does include yeah it is a spectrum yeah
for sure so so the challenge when having
conversations actually someone super
chatted this they said there's no middle
ground that's only uninformed people or
something like that and so the issue is
I would disagree I think that person
probably has 40 different things that
they most likely down in checklist like
this this this this and if somebody
disagrees with them on one of them it
depends on where you're where you're at
right if so if you're an economic left
unlike Healthcare and you go to a
healthcare convention where there's like
a bunch of conservatives talking and
you're arguing for universal healthcare
they're going to call you a leftist you
know what I mean so if it depends on
which issue your particular you're
specifically on yeah but uh to back to
my earlier point though
uh that the point I made earlier
if you're in the middle genuinely and
you stand up and speak out you are
instantly right wing so for instance
these uh the reason the NCAA swimmers
won't speak up about the biological mail
in the competition is because as they've
stated privately they're scared they'll
be ostracized or kicked out and won't be
able to compete or they'll lose all
their career opportunities they'll be
kicked out of school or generally just
have their life ruined
these are people who are in the middle I
mean these These are these are people
who are not pronounced uh you know uh
one way or the other who can't say a
word because they'll be called far right
if someone if I want to give a speech
and someone start calling me a name like
hey write us hey you're far left hey
you're a Centrist I would see that as
them deflecting what I'm talking about
and avoiding the conversation it's just
kind of like a placation it doesn't it
doesn't people try to figure out who you
are so they could figure out whether
they should dismiss your beliefs without
engaging with them
what a crazy world we live in yeah I
understand that you do want to discern
like I don't want to go smell the poop
to know that it stinks I already know it
stinks so like I don't need to know
every piece of poop to know that poop
stinks covered for me was one of the
best examples that there was very that
there was somewhat diminishing middle
ground and public discourse like for
instance I'll get all of these comments
that say you know the reason that this
stuff still exists is because idiots
like you were wearing a mask in the
beginning the more you if you comply you
will never stop it's like I had people
in the store were wearing masks back
when the television told us that you
were a hypochondriac if you did that
right we did that because I told them
very clearly if everybody gets sick at
the same time payroll here is twenty
thousand dollars a week rent is twelve
thousand a month uh here's how much
money is in the bank here's how much I
can afford to pay you all if you all get
sick and we don't have any money so
everybody decided to wear one uh you
know just just if because we didn't know
what the hell was going on yet so let's
just stay safe but I didn't close my
business I'm not going to close my
business and just you know not make
anything for that entire time and just
economically destroy myself so people
who were a little bit more left would
say you know you're I got hate mail
under my door for April of 2020 like
consistently
um for being open yeah because I was
staying there to finish the shipping
because the shipping person and the the
receptionists were staying home so I was
doing the job of both so I would stay a
little late and I would go to the
bathroom after closing the lights and
come back and I'd see hate Melody by
door after eight but there was a you
know they would say how dare you you're
some evil capital is staying open and
then people that were on the right would
say you know you [ __ ] why are you
wearing a mask and it's like I mean I'm
not saying that you should have to close
your business I'm not saying that you
should have to close your business but
uh but I'm going to do the basic things
that I can do just to if there's any
chance of it increasing my likelihood of
surviving and increasing likely to the
business surviving why not and it's like
it was just one or the other from so
many people and it was very boring so
the person said there's no middle ground
I think there is Middle Ground like even
on an issue like covet I am not going to
say it's usually either this doesn't
exist this is a hoax you're an idiot or
be afraid until 2030 and it's like there
is a middle ground of I will live my
life here are the minor modifications I
will make that don't have a cost here
are the modifications that have a great
cost that I'm not willing to make and I
you know I weigh it and I do it that way
but is the middle ground having an
impact on policy
is the middle ground having an impact on
policy yeah I think the answer is no
well I did see the CBS has did an
article about Hunter Biden's laptop it's
on CBS now I think the us being kind of
a middle ground I feel like a Middle
Ground Force pushing this Hunter Biden
thing it's it's broken through it's
affecting policy only if it doesn't
matter if it's possible right or the
answer it doesn't matter I mean just to
get that knowledge out into the
mainstream is important because it may
in 2024 ended up being a bigger deal
than we realized
yeah yeah maybe but um I wonder if that
has anything to do with the middle
ground I mean the the conversation's
laptop needed to happen in October and
it was shut down by big Tech and in the
corporate press I don't think the middle
ground has as much of a of an effect on
policy if it did again in New York uh
you had Mass mandates business closures
and everything else in other states
they're saying if you want some if you
let's say if this if you ask the schools
to make people wear masks you know we're
not going to give you money so it's
literally one way or the other it's not
it's the the radicals on each side that
have that that has an effect on policy
but see so here's the issue I take with
that is if uh in Florida they say
schools can't require masks that's the
government telling the government it has
restrictions if the government tells a
private individual they can't open their
business that's the government imposing
on private individuals one's bad one's
government restriction I would rather
err on the Florida side than the New
York side just to make it obvious where
I am there but uh I didn't even know if
our that order applied to repair shops
because they actually edited on March
20th 2020 when Cuomo did the pause order
it read as if the only places that can
stay open are places that are doing
technology repair for the government and
then they edited the website to make it
sound like it was anybody that is doing
technology repair but I still stayed
open I would ER on the side of Florida
before the side of New York the other
thing is in terms of the coveted
response at the governmental level the
left would say like oh Trump's failures
or the Republicans failures led to
ex-deaths whereas you had you know Cuomo
wolf you had what's his face in New
Jersey was it what was it Murphy Murphy
yeah you had um
you had Whitmer and and who else did it
who else was the other Governor some I
think uh Illinois
they all literally murdered people right
yeah right so they so during covet they
they actually with knowledge put coveted
patients in nursing homes resulting in
Mass death right Cuomo for instance was
warned by like his his chief of health
or whatever if you put sick people in
nursing homes you will kill people it
doesn't strike me as the type of person
that likes to be told no by anybody but
but so so think about what that means I
mean on the right it's like we're not
going to in the government will not
intervene but then people will die if
you don't well you know it's your
responsibility to figure out for
yourself the government's not going to
impose on the private establishments
though they you know they do for a lot
of reasons in this instance they were
you know limited and then in all of
these big Democrat governorship States
they were like I mean we'll literally
kill people like they didn't have to you
know in New York they had the Javits
Center they could have put sick people
in the Javit Center only reach 30
capacity they use that they they think
they didn't have the US Army Corps of
Engineers build a hospital in the Javits
Center they did and it was that 30
capacity but instead of putting patients
there Cuomo said you know he'd rather
just kill elderly people in nursing
homes I know they sent the USS Comfort
but there were a lot of complaints
saying that they were not allowed to
take a bunch of different patients so it
kind of wound up they they claimed it
was more of a PR stunt for Trump than it
was actually helping I only read one
article on that so I'm not as well
informed but I know that the Javits
Center was supposed to be built to be a
hospital yeah and it wasn't it wasn't
used like I mean 30 I think was the was
as high as it got yeah and then 70 of
the real estate that City probably isn't
even used maybe they could have built a
lot so so you know therein lies the main
point if you know once again back to the
what we're talking about if you go to
the middle and ask them they'd say put
the sick people in the Javits Center
but the Democratic establishment was
like no kill kill the elderly in the
nursing homes and and it was done in
like five different states was that the
Democratic establishment or was that
Cuomo being a dumbass that if it was
just Cuomo then you would have seen it
with Whitmer Murphy wolf and Newsome all
of these different Democrat Governors
all doing the same thing did they all
have a nursing home Scandal because I
didn't follow every other state the only
thing I know about winter was the
Walmart thing where you're allowed to go
on aisle 11 but not 13. right yeah let's
triple check though you wanna can you
wanna pull that up I'm pretty sure they
all did the same thing yeah I believe so
and in fact yeah yeah in in Pennsylvania
it was Rachel Levine the transgender
Admiral took her mother out he took
their their parents out of the nursing
homes before they did it right so I mean
they knew what they were doing well one
of our friends Charlie Lee Duff is
actually suing Governor Whitmer over
this stuff right yeah so I know it
happened there and it wasn't as big a
scandal as it was with Cuomo but it was
a very real problem for that yeah it was
like almost like yeah I thought from the
Cuomo thing but it is a big deal yeah
you got it too Tim so so all these
Governors did the same thing and the
people at the highest level knew what
was going on clearly now it's possible
it wasn't coordinated but that they were
at least communicating as to what was
happening with each other and taking
actions meanwhile regular people were
seeing their parents die in nursing
homes so again you go to an average
person in the middle and they'll be like
hey this is really really bad but if you
come out and say the things we're saying
right now they'll call you right wing I
I'm
maybe I can talk about this later I'm
just looking at Rachel Levine all right
we'll we'll set it for the afternoon the
health minister of the United States
that's very healthy yeah let's talk
about New York yes let's talk about New
York City we got this in the Daily Mail
NYC has worst unemployment rate in the
U.S at 7.6 because Manhattan workers and
international tourists still haven't
returned to crime-ridden city post covet
I don't think it's the crime I think
it's the expense I mean if you have a
business that was most people don't like
change most companies don't like change
so if you have a company that's
massively profitable why would you want
to switch your entire management style
and take a giant Risk by having
everybody work from home but if your arm
is twisted and you have no choice it's
either a you go out of business or B you
figure out how to make people work from
home you'll figure out how to make
people work from home and then once you
figure out how to make everybody work
from home now you can say you know what
instead of paying 300 000 a month in
rent for the entire floor of this office
what if we just paid 10 for a satellite
office you're saving 290 000 a month and
if that's the case why are you going to
have everybody return what's the point
like I I've walked home several times
from you know my to my old apartment in
MedStar from Manhattan on 27th Street I
I didn't maybe it's just because I'm
used to it or I grew up there I'm
missing something but I haven't felt any
fear of crime on my walk home more than
at least what I've ever felt right but
it's just all these places all these
Office Buildings all these stores or
they all say for rent I think that's the
reason it's just if the office workers
haven't returned if the businesses
haven't returned then there's going to
be less work for people think about
think about this too if you're a
business based in New York let's say
you're like BuzzFeed right and you all
you really do is you have people sit
around writing articles about stupid
garbage but they could write those
garbage articles anywhere yeah now cost
of living in New York is high it's very
odds I think it's the highest in the in
the country right I think so it goes up
every year it was up every year and plus
New York city has the highest taxes
highest income taxes so New York State
plus city taxes makes your income your
income tax the highest California as a
state has the highest but I think New
York City having like it was like a
three percent like three or three and a
half percent for City six or six and a
half percent for State yeah and the
goods they think it's slightly lower if
you make less but that's approximately
what it is I don't even think it's the
tax that does it I think it's just the
sheer well no no not having to come back
to work no no the point I'm making what
I'm pointing out with the with the taxes
is that the cost of living is high the
average person needs to make like six
figures to have a middle class life I
think New Year it's like 150 to 175k you
need to make to be considered middle
class because of the cost of living
being so high like three thousand
dollars on average for rent I think it's
gone up to like four so your BuzzFeed
and you're like if I want to hire
someone in New York to come in the
office and write about you know Brad
Pitt's junk or whatever I got to spend
175k for a mid-tier talent okay well you
know in rural you know up Upstate or
even in like Central PA where the cost
of living is low they can do the same
work we can do virtual meetings you can
metaverse or whatever
we can pay him 60. all right I hire the
guy in PA so now the dude who's sitting
in New York who's Talent uh tree
includes writing about Brad Pitt's junk
is sitting there be like I can't get a
job anywhere do you think that
California making it I think what they
did was made it illegal to have people
not be employees but to be contractors
for oh yeah writers and vloggers you
know that was a good or a bad mood bad
move it wiped out so much of their
digital industry it's it's a laugh it'll
be bad it was the unions that pushed for
this bill did you hear about this in
California so this was I think like two
years ago or more longer the Union's
push for this bill that said companies
can't Contra hire contractors for a
certain amount of tasks and so this
would result in like uber having to hire
people I think I don't I think Uber may
have got an amendment that defeated or
something but it meant that if you if
you uh were a writer a freelance writer
you could only write like 30 articles
per year or something like that it was
like month yeah it was a really low
amount yeah so like the average person
might write like five or six articles
per day now you can only do 30. well the
company in the California company just
says okay your contract's terminated the
guy in Arizona who can write the same
thing for me and he can work all day
every day because Arizona doesn't have
those laws or or actually what it was is
companies in New York fired all of their
California contractors and Freelancers
just overnight all these it was it was
like SB Nation a Vox company like
terminated all of their California it
just doesn't synergize with the coveted
Narrative of work from home well this
was before coven yeah it was a fork of
it I wonder if it was like a prep for
this kind of contingency I don't know
the working from home thing changed my
life I used to work always out in
location and then 2010 I started working
with mine so we just kind of worked from
our laptops from a Starbucks or wherever
and man the commute is really draining I
don't know you you say you take your
electric bike to work now that might
that might be kind of refreshing 20
minutes it's fun but still even if I
didn't actually have to make that 20 or
30 minute trip why would I exactly and
especially if I could pay 1 000 in rent
instead of 12 000 in rent then why would
I not do that I think a lot of this is
driven by economics more than it is by
crime so but you have you have a
physical location in New York City right
unfortunately so people have to
physically walk in and hand you
something to fix so you can't I mean you
could theoretically do the remote if
what you bought something in the middle
of nowhere and said ship me your phone
and I'll fix it yeah but that would
still require the employees to commute
to that location and do the job yeah I
just mean for like New York City like
your job requires you to be a service on
the ground in New York City for people
of New York City some things you're
we're not going to be able to you know
automate or remote or whatever some
things are never going to really be
remote fully remote but a lot of stuff
is does this you know have has it has it
forced you to spend more money or I'm
sorry to charge more money for your
services in New York City like the fact
that
industry you know all these buildings
are shut down less people are working on
employment's very very high you having
to have a physical brick and mortar
location I'd assume costs are going up
right my cost all my prices went up in
2012 when I opened a real store rather
than just you know work out of the park
or anything like that I haven't raised
my prices anymore now because when
people lose their jobs and everything
else costs more money they tend to not
want to spend more money on their
repairs if your grocery bill is twice as
much and you just lost your job from
covid you're probably not if anything
people were asking for discounts
non-stop in 2020 and early 2021 but have
your costs gone up now in the past
couple of years with pandemic my costs
haven't gone up as a business they went
up not because of the what happened but
because I moved in 2019 and pretty much
the worst possible time I almost tripled
my rent at the worst possible time
because business was doing this and then
literally I move and then it's like but
food prices are up as well I mean food
and gas and everything is up that's got
to have an impact on your business right
personal uh personal yes for the
business now really I just feel like in
in the long run from this
all of it points towards certain things
are going to become more expensive
certain things are going to become
cheaper things that have to be physical
will probably get more expensive and
things that don't have to be will
probably get cheaper I don't see how
rent can get any more expensive in New
York City but it continues to I know
what how are is it getting to a point
where they're like hey no one lives here
anymore let's just drop the rent back
down to I don't believe anything I don't
think anything there is supposed to be
rented like this started as a I didn't I
didn't even intend for this to be like a
real video series I just was looking for
a new store in 2019 and I was so
aggravated that every time I'd see a
place they lied about it I said I'm
gonna buy one of those little laser
measures and I'm going to record the
next time what do they lie about well
they would say it was 1800 square feet I
would show up and it would be 800 and
then I would just I have my camera and I
go okay so this says 800 you said 1800
why and that video series was probably
the most successful thing I've ever done
on YouTube like 99 of my channel
probably doesn't even know that I fix
MacBooks they just see me as a real
estate person because of that but all of
these a lot of these places they would
say you know if you don't rent it it
will be rented next week we have all
these clients lined up and then I'll
show up a year or two or three years
later and it's all empty and it's so why
don't once you lower the price like a
little bit you have spaces that are the
size of my store which was 12 500 when I
first rented it they were going for 75
000 a month and it's the same size as my
location just two blocks this way and
they they still won't be rented three or
four or five years later and more and
more of the city looks like this and the
prices never go down with anything the
office you know the uh the office prices
stay like that and they stay empty so
this was happening before covid like the
fact I they were just something needed
to happen to kind of prick this little
box has it gotten better or it's still
getting worse or what no I mean I still
walk by these places every day are they
owned by Mega Corps that are writing off
the losses on their taxes or something I
have no idea the best thing
the best thing that I can imagine was is
uh one gentleman I'll quote on Reddit
laminar flow who was saying that a lot
of these properties let's say the
mortgage will be owned by a bunch of
investors as a commercial
mortgage-backed security and I'm
probably misphrasing this because I've
read it a year and a half ago but you
can't simply if the if you lower the
rents in the property the value of it
goes down the value of it goes down well
your your collateral is the actual
building which means that the owner of
the property would have to give up that
amount of money or it just you know well
no that'd be default on the market you'd
write off your losses you could you
could save money on taxes by doing that
no you you can't if you actually
advertise the bill the space at a lower
rent it winds up saying meaning that the
building is worth less and if the
building is worth less than your own oh
but if you have a mortgage on it your
collateral is a building so then you so
let's say the building is worth three
million now it's worth two well you as
the building owner needs to now give the
bank one million dollars in collateral
in cash or in something else I don't I
don't I don't think that's true I mean I
have mortgages and stuff
I did read this on Reddit and I I do
think it is possible for mortgages to
call in if the value of the house drops
too low and the bank panics but I'm but
I'm not sure exactly how that works I
don't know how it works with commercial
mortgage-backed Securities it was the
closest thing that sounded like it made
any sense but I can't pretend I know I
think what might be happening right now
is
prices because uh demand is is low
prices actually are dropping but the
reason you see the rent staying you know
going up going up is because inflation
is actually outpacing the rate at which
the building should be decreasing in
value based on supply and demand you
know what I mean you know a lot of these
spaces are still going for 100 to 500 a
square foot yeah and it's like that that
doesn't make sense that didn't even make
sense before coffee because before covet
these spaces were all empty so after
covet one if people have left then that
definitely doesn't make sense well
before covet it's just New York Prime
real estate you're going to hold on to
it because it's valuable during covid
everything was you know decreasing in
value but inflation was actually getting
really really bad and it's been
consistently bad every month at for the
past what six months every month it's
like inflation is at a record inflation
is at a new record inflation it's like
inflation hasn't been as high this High
since the 80s since the 80s and it's
it's going up every a little bit if you
actually do the calculation based on the
80s numbers then uh inflation right now
is actually the worst it's been since
World War II then you also see the
accusations I think it might have been
Thomas Massey who said this uh Nancy
Pelosi and Pelosi included a 21
Congressional budget increase
either that means she's giving everybody
like a big raise during a crisis
or to cover the cost of inflation for
their Congressional budgets they just
did a 21 increase which says a whole lot
about inflation might actually be so if
the the actual demand for these places
is non-existent or gone down
dramatically then it should go from 100
a square foot to maybe 30 a square foot
right that inflation hits and it spikes
right back up because New York and
things are just getting crummy even if
it was 20 inflation if it went from 100
to 30 then it should only go up to let's
say 36 or 38 or 40. but I mean like New
York is it has a substantially higher
cost of living so going from 100 to 30
was just medium hyperbolic if it goes
from 100 to like you know 80 85 and then
it jumps up another 16 it goes back up
to 100. so inflation I mean maybe that's
I'm just speculating to be completely
honest I I honestly don't know where
we're going to go from here because I
think you know almost all work we're
seeing now from most of the millennial
generation and lower is just not real
work you know typically honest I what
we're doing is work like we you know we
show we I read the news all day every
day so I know stuff and I and I read all
this stuff
but man it's kind of crazy to me that we
sit in a room talking about things and
it generates Revenue yeah and I can buy
food with it man I don't make bread I
don't Farm anything that's wild there
are people who work at BuzzFeed who like
I said write about Brad Pitt's junk or
whatever and they make sixty thousand
dollars a year and it's crazy because
the Dude loading the plane I swear I
think we're very close to some kind of
you know occupy style Revolt or whatever
maybe this will be a catalyst in the
Civil War or something like that that
the people who load planes so that you
can travel around get paid probably 15
bucks an hour at this point yet the dude
sitting in an office in New York with a
finger up their nose wondering like how
can I call Trump racist today is getting
paid forty dollars an hour
yeah that that is mind-blowing to me
something something doesn't make sense
yeah yeah certainly I think Working
Class People are going to lose it and
just be like I am done with whatever
this is I mean think about this let's
say you work as you know at an airline
and I I say this job because I did it
and we got paid 10 bucks an hour back in
like 2008. let's say you're working that
job and you're getting 15 bucks an hour
right now or maybe even 20 still and
then you're doing this job and you look
up in that plane and you're thinking to
yourself like you know truth be told
when you work with these companies you
get to fly for free you get to you could
you have to pay the taxes on it but you
get non-rev flights standby but you're
wondering like what is that guy up there
doing that 25 year old do with those
thick black frame glasses what does he
do for a living that he gets to fly on
this trip to Nassau to go to the Bahamas
man I wish I could do that here I am
doing all of this hard back breaking
work 50 000 pounds per day loading these
planes and I don't make enough money to
go on these vacations and who's that guy
I wonder what his job is now these guys
are probably assuming like must be a
tech guy must be a finance guy and then
the dude up there with the black frame
glasses is like Brad Pitt's junk was
seen in a movie today and he's making
all that money so he can fly to the
Bahamas like this system is broken if
you were to ask me yeah I have a feeling
that the mega corpse are coming to buy
all the land not all the land but a lot
of property yeah like BlackRock um State
Street they're going to buy up a bunch
of property and then there may be a
revolt on American revolt against the
corporate land owners because it's like
you may own it on paper but if you're
not there you don't really have control
of the property
um they'll have private security and
then it's up to is the American
government going to support the
corporations and the the law that says
that they own it or are they going to
support the people and the freedom
against corporate Monopoly because if
you want to print 80 trillion dollars
and then give it to Blackrock to buy 80
trillion worth of property before
inflation and then destroy the economy
BlackRock doesn't get to own that
property you will owe nothing and you
will be happy well I suspect what's more
likely to foment a revolution because
this infuriated me and I'm incredibly
patient uh with something like the
Bloomberg opinion talking about ways to
save money some of the things you can do
are not treat your pet if they have
cancer take the bus and eat lentils
instead of meat so we did it actually
say not treat your pet if they literally
said that well yeah same look as soon as
or later you all will realize you will
own nothing and you'll be happy yeah
also lentils are banging by the way
that's fine yeah lentils are fine I
don't care about that well let's let's
talk about owning nothing and being
happy yes yeah we have the story from
wired it's actually from a month ago but
it gets into the core of right to repair
it says a fight over the right to repair
cars turns ugly in the wake of a voter
approved law Subaru and Kia dealers in
Massachusetts have disabled systems that
allow remote starts and send maintenance
alerts now I'm not super interested just
in that because I'll talk about the
bigger picture but I think the show's an
interesting you know uh issue as it
pertains to these big corporations and
the rest of us who will eventually own
nothing and be happy I just like to
point out like your iPhone what is it
you don't actually own the software on
you have a license to it and they could
break oh you can keep the phone but
we'll brick it remotely because we own
the software you lose your license to it
this is a problem because we're losing
ownership and things we don't own movies
anymore we don't own the software on
computers and when it comes to you
actually buying a phone you can't even
fix it without the company what they're
they're denying your warranties you want
it so so Louis you're actually the right
to repair guy right
yeah I try to be all right so tell us
what's going on with this and uh yeah
what's what's up with the what this
means there was a 2012 uh law that was
passed in Massachusetts where the the
automotive manufacturers would have to
give independent deal Independence
mechanics access to what's needed to be
able to repair your car so diagnostic
software and everything else you'd have
to make that available to them and there
was one loophole in it with regard to
wireless so there was a so if you are
doing all this stuff wirelessly then you
won't have to deal with that law so they
were trying to close that loophole
before everything winds up being done
wirelessly so that they don't get locked
out and there was a ballot initiative
and I believe it was 75 in favor 25
opposed and a group called Coalition get
rid of the wireless loophole or what
well to pass this so that there wouldn't
be any sort of loophole so then you'd
still be able to and the idea that
they're saying is that people now if you
allow these independent mechanics to be
able to use diagnostic software on the
car that they are and also they were
going to to create and open some sort of
open data protocol so that they would be
able to access it that they would then
be able to follow you to a garage and
sexually assault you what well there
were a bunch of commercials done where
there was a woman walking to her car and
it was a nice very very dark blue
lighting and she's getting into her car
and this scary music is playing and
right is before she opens her car window
she looks behind herself and she's about
to get smacked by some dude and the
implication is that that dude is the car
mechanic these videos our mechanic was
kidnapping women and then there was
another one with his car mechanica
slowly walking up on the garage as this
woman is slowly closing the garage door
and he opens it up and then he walks
into her home and you hear the scary
music playing in the background the
implications that's the dude that fixes
your car so one and this was paid for by
Ford Honda Nissan General Motors and
Toyota they each contributed four to
five million dollars for those
commercials they were all scrubbed from
the internet entirely because why would
you want to be associated with this
after you lose but I archived them on my
channel and there was and that's what
they were doing to try to get people to
vote against it is there a way to search
for this real quick while you're talking
it's on my channel I think it's uh right
to I forget the title of my own video
which is really real remember
it's somewhere on my channel but if you
look for uh if you if you just look for
the ballot initiative what do you search
for I don't know right to repair sexual
assault probably is what how long ago
was it this was in August of 2020. okay
so not too long yeah this was August
2020 that I made that video and I I put
the video there and you can't find it
anymore and their website is completely
scrubbed they were trying to scare your
average voter into believing that if
Independents are able to work on your
car that they'll be able to assault you
in a parking lot and break into your
home called lobbyist Supply right to
repair helps domestic abusers push
racism yeah that's it that's it that's
it yeah and they also they also said it
was race via Supply right to repair if
you search that they also said it was
racist which is something we got accused
of In This Very state that right to
repair was racist yeah I got accused of
that literally two weeks ago uh it's in
this video so if you fast forward to a
minute there you go there you go let's
play this playlist all right personal
data stored in your vehicle domestic
violence Advocates say a sexual predator
could use the data to stalk their
victims pinpoint exactly where you are
whether you are alone
even take control of your vehicle
vote no questions
should be looking behind herself the
whole time she's walking through that
place alone firstly yeah and then well
like you'd hear footsteps yeah really
yeah so they they are looking to
overturn that ballot initiative and
they've been in court for this entire
time and the judge is actually starting
to get kind of aggravated with their
arguments and what they're saying
because they said it's impossible for us
to comply with this yet then Kia and
Subaru complied by simply disabling
their Wireless Systems altogether which
is it's a discussion as to whether
that's complying with it or evading it
but it aggravated the judge so the judge
is likely gonna there's a good chance
that this winds up getting held up and
uh yeah I mean if you buy a car you
should be able to fix it you should be
able to get access to the diagnostic
tools it shouldn't be something where
it's like dealing with apple where you
if you want to be able to diagnose it
you have to wait for somebody to get a
stolen schematic off of a truck in China
somewhere so that you could fix the
Forty thousand dollar car that you own I
just want to point out the absurdity of
them trying to play the racism angle
where it's just like they're probably
sitting in a room like how can we get
people to not be okay with this oh call
them racist that that actually worked so
in my in March of 2020 there was a right
to repair Bill Hearing in in Maryland
and there was one person who said you
know this bill talks about making source
code available which it doesn't it
doesn't mention source code once that's
never in the bill and I said you know
this and he said that well you know by
the way viruses don't just appear out of
nowhere they appear because people have
access to the source code you can
immediately hear every single person who
was a Linux developer or a systems
administrator who knows that over 60 of
the internet is run on Linux which is
open source it's like just banging their
head against the wall this thing so I
did a video saying with the testimony
because I went there to record it and I
also testified in this hearing to
explain why this was wrong and I
listened to that video I've listened
that video like 100 times since I did it
I don't hear anything racist in it I try
to channel my own like ibrahamex candy
or you know Robin D'Angelo to try to
figure out what I could have said or
done that was wrong and I don't see it
even my comments I read through it had
300 comments at the time it was a it was
uh this is who's stopping right to
repair in Maryland from March of 2020
and I it there's nothing racist in it
there are a lot of comments saying this
politician is a [ __ ] wow I can't
believe this guy got elected what an
idiot which is normal political
discourse in our country regardless of
race but he had said the re so when we
hired a lobbyist in that state they said
that that was a racist video and that's
why they weren't gonna to consider right
to repair so then the lobbyist said well
listen here my client is willing to
personally come down here on a trip you
know uh come to your office and
apologize and discuss anything with you
he's like no don't worry about water
runs of the bridge then two weeks ago
they say oh yeah there was a very racist
video that was done and I'm not I'm not
going to consider this bill it's like
like really and I've I've literally read
through every single comment every
single one of the 300 comments because
you'll see there there are comment
sections on YouTube where they'll say
you know oh that like look look at that
set of Runners where the runner means
jogger and jogger means n-word for
somebody that doesn't actually want to
say it none of it it was it was clean as
can be it was just idiot dumbass
whatever they're lying bro and and but
the thing is it worked right because
that bill is gone now but this is what I
was talking to about Middle Ground
people you think average Middle Ground
people would if you talk to them and
explain to them what happened they'd be
on your side I don't know a single
left-wing person that watched that video
of what he was claiming that even agree
with him even people that I know that
are Larry left wing but it was like that
that's full of it what was the actual
client so who was the politician who
who's like not getting on board CT
Wilson he's a democrat or a republican
he is all right well
I've been the thing is right to repair
has been screwed over by Republicans
Democrats and Libertarians in almost
every single state Libertarians yes
folks so in Nebraska that's surprising
no in Nebraska Republican I get you know
Democrat I get Nebraska in 20 in 2017
there was a Senator Bob Crist who agreed
to meet with all of us the day of the
hearing and then he called off the
hearing and then he he didn't he wasn't
interested in it uh Mueller rollback Kim
romack who was an ATT lobbyist donated
three thousand dollars I thought that
that's nothing maybe the cost of living
is different in Nebraska and that's all
it takes but yeah he was going to meet
with us he called it off last minute you
go to followthemoney.org and that day
you seek uh Kim roback uh the ATT who
used to be lieutenant governor who was
an ATT lobbyist who testified against
the bill gave him money uh Ernie
Chambers this is interesting Ernie
Chambers who is a very left-leaning
Democrat and if you go to
followthemoney.org actually has no
there's no company giving him money he
is purely fundraised by his neighbors
and everybody going door to door
knocking and people giving him a dollar
he said and I quote to consider this
bill strike all contents from the bill
and write in the following better luck
next year and then he started laughing
at us what then he started laughing at
us Laura Epp who was a Libertarian sat
next to him also left by the way she was
voted out of office by Tom brand no she
she was beat out of office by Tom brand
who is a republican who was a farmer who
won an election based on right to repair
in Washington state the Democrats voted
for it every single person who voted
against right to repair who didn't want
it to move forward was a Republican and
in Washington state the interesting
thing is in Nebraska this time around
it was actually Urban Democrats that
voted for right to repair and Rural
Republicans that were endorsed by the
Nebraska Farm Bureau that voted against
it and a part of me wonders is this just
them trolling are they just trying to
say like are they trying to actually get
the rural vote and say listen you guys
see us all as City Slickers they're
voting against you being able to fix
your own tractor we don't even know what
a tractor is and we're voting for it so
why don't you consider voting but in
every state it's been very eclectic who
supports it and who declines who denies
it it's a total twin toss you know I'm
willing to bet it has a lot to do with
uh you know for Farmers you've got a lot
of these big companies it's not so much
the farmers is the politician and they
say we're going to run ads against you
and make you look as bad as possible to
every one of your constituents you know
the amount of money we will dump into
destroying you you will never compete
with and they say okay I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna bother that's another thing
that's been very interesting is figuring
out who is for this and who is against
this so when I started actually when I
did the fundraiser last year I wanted to
go to the ballot initiative in the state
of Massachusetts that was my goal to try
and get it passed by people and just
bypass this entire disgusting process
also together I said if I raise three to
six million I'll do it if I don't I'll
just do traditional lobbying to try to
get something passed in this thing so
there's a state where I am try I we
introduced a bill that does not exclude
farm equipment and there was someone who
was asking to be excluded from farm
equipment and it was a Farm Bureau now
this is no so I had to have a Converse
so I I get an email from uh that's from
my lobbyist I would have not shared but
at this point I don't care because I got
called racist by senators in the state
and the bill got killed anyway he said
you probably shouldn't share this
because if you share stuff like this do
you want to get a bill passed or do you
just want to stir up stuff but it's like
well I didn't get a bill pass doing it
your way anyway so I get an I see an
email saying it's still a tough issue to
address our problem isn't a non-ability
to repair our own equipment but more a
lack of service providers in key times
of the year key part most Farmers don't
have or care to have the knowledge or
the equipment to repair their own
equipment so it's a service provider
issue tell that to a farmer tell that to
a farmer that most Farmers don't have
the knowledge or the ability to repair
their own stuff well farmers are all
dumb so no but this is somebody that rep
presents Farmers that is saying this
this is somebody from a Farm Bureau so I
say listen I can't let this go I know
I'm supposed to let this go I can't let
this go I give the guy a call it's like
yo you emailed my lobbyist do I hired I
know that you know that he was going to
send this to me I am I I you know I grew
up in Brooklyn I've never been in a farm
in my life so if I show up to a state
and I start advocating for right to
repair and then we remove agriculture
from the bill that's going to look like
this New York City per City slick or
whatever is is trying to screw over
farmers do you understand how it looks
for me now you're the one who's asking
to be removed from the bill and you're
saying if you're not moving the bill
that you're probably going to ask to be
removed and that's going to be awkward
so we should ask to be removed so I need
you to understand how bad this would
look for me if I was to remove it can
you explain why you want to be removed
from this bill and can you explain how I
can explain in a PR friendly way why it
is you're asking to be removed when
you're saying that you support farmers
and can you please explain this line
that you told me most Farmers don't have
or care to have the knowledge of the
equipment to repair their own equipment
and the answer that I got was in my
opinion garbage so there's there's there
this is politics man you look if you if
you play it honest and honorable you'll
get stampeded over and crushed by the
people who are willing to lie cheers I
got stampeded I absolutely got Stampede
and the thing is and the idea you can
share this if you share that then you'll
look bad I didn't share I did exactly I
love sharing I did exactly what I was
supposed to do and then it was caring
and then you know this is it did
anything win no it wasn't going to win
anyway but
I like I like sharing the details I like
letting people know I want people to
know exactly who's screwed absolutely
and I'm doing that at every single
chance that I get in every single state
I'm Point like with Nebraska I pointed
out by the way here are all the people
that are endorsed by the Farm Bureau
here are all the people that voted
against it do you see that all the
people that voted against it are
endorsed by the Farm Bureau so what what
you know what you're proposing is like
simple that people who say buy a tractor
are allowed to fix their own tractor I'm
saying that make available the
Diagnostics the schematics and the tools
at or fair and reasonable price that you
make available to your own dealers OR
technician so if you sell this if you
sell the software package to a dealer
for five thousand let them buy it for
five thousand if you sell if if you sell
this schematic for you know 500 or this
this manual for 500 sell it to the
independent for 500 right now I Rely for
my business on stuff that fell off the
back of a truck it's all like the the
process that I go through to get access
to screens and ships my my customers
think that I just go to mouser.com and I
just buy everything that I want they
have no idea that Nicholas Cage Lord of
War supply chain ridiculous nonsense
that happened in the background so that
I could get them a computer screen but
there's yeah like this this plays into
phones and stuff as well right like it
goes yeah it's it's with almost
everything and you know one of the
things that drives me nuts is when
people say just don't buy apple and
it'll go away I talk about Apple
products because that's what I fix but
show me a smartphone where you can get
the schematic from the company even
fairphone who says they support right to
repair will not give you a schematic for
any amount of money what about freedom
freedom phone Freedom pool yeah Freedom
funnel I think the only thing that would
give you I think because they buy it
third party I haven't double checked if
this is the case but I think Pine phone
will but if you use it it is
they're a great company it's a bit far
from the experience the experience that
you'll get if you buy you know a s10e or
uh or an iPhone 10 or anything like that
they're getting there but they're but
like there's no if you want to have
access to things like this you really
have to give up the ability to live in a
modern society you know you can't get a
schematic to your monitor you can't buy
like you can't buy chips to a lot of the
things that you want to and is the is
the challenge though like copyright a
lot of Ip yeah what they'll say is
they'll say that it's that it is a an
intellectual property issue but here's
the actual issue I think it is I don't
think it's an issue of if we release the
schematic somebody else will reproduce
our product because if you go to
venafix.com or you know notebook squad
or any of these places you'll be you
could spend 20 bucks and get access to
all the schematics well not just that
I'm pretty sure every major phone
company buys every brand new phone and
just opens it and goes oh I think here's
I think here's the issue they're afraid
if the schematics get out that it won't
be that that users or other companies
will copy their technology but rather
it'll show up that they were already
copying everybody to begin with I'm
seeing I think that's a part of it so
for instance let's say you pay a company
and this is this is my speculation based
on what I've heard from people in the
industry that I don't want to give their
name out because they they were probably
doing this but they let's say you ask
company in China you know we want a lot
we want a laptop motherboard with these
specifications and this chipset and this
blah blah modem and blah blah that
company that's actually doing everything
in Taiwan a career or China are they
going to start from scratch to make it
just for you or are they going to say
well Dell or Lenovo contracted us to
make this control C control V here you
go so there's a so there's a lot of
Technology out there where you it
probably is a direct copy and paste of
somebody else's thing and especially in
China yeah because they're doing it
because they don't care but here our
laws say that we care so if you keep the
schematic and everything private you
can't really see that versus if you make
it public then maybe it's a little bit
more easy to see that wait you copy my
Bluetooth circuit you copied this
circuit or something like that that's my
best case but the like you used to be if
you bought a radio or you bought a
television you bought all these any of
this different stuff you would open it
and there'd be a schematic on the back
of it that shows everything's put
together and you could buy manuals to it
I mean you know even for the uh you know
for the all for computers back in the
day they used to come with schematics
and manuals that show you how to fix
everything and the argument that gets
used now is security and safety that we
that we would be less secure and less
safe but were people like blowing
themselves up fixing their toasters 50
years ago no we had a much more
freedom-oriented mindset back then did
you say that OnStar I felt like I talked
over you were talking about an OnStar
can track where people are in their cars
and like you were saying with this this
propaganda commercial that if a woman's
walking to her car in the middle of
night people from OnStar know that yeah
I mean if I'm if I'm gonna like I'm not
gonna spend five thousand dollars for
all these different tools if I'm if I
want to abuse my wife I'm not going to
do all of this I'm probably just going
to toss an air tag onto the mattresses
that matter something yeah yeah yeah not
that I do that like not only that I mean
a lot of these there's there's a million
and one ways to track vehicles there are
so many ways to track people that are
easier than hacking into the open data
system in your cars get you know get on
stuff complicated ways to track somebody
no it's ridiculous and again this is
designed to scare you and the thing that
a lot of people don't get is a lot of
people will say Tesla is anti-repair in
many ways true however who funded this
Ford General Motors Toyota Nissan and
Honda and the reason that all the stuff
is scrubbed from the internet right
after they lost is because they don't
want to have that anti-repair reputation
they don't want to be known as the
company that Associated being sexually
assaulted with uh with having a car
repaired but they should be because they
paid for this yeah Tesla open sourced
all their patents I don't know all our
patent are belong to you tesla.com from
2019 yeah elon's a weird guy he's a
funny dude also have you guys heard of
good stuff but he's also yeah he's a
very strange man I love him yeah open
sourceecology.org if you guys ever seen
this it's Mar I think it's pronounced
Martin
jakubowski is his name but he's
basically created all these Farm all
this farm equipment in these open source
all the patents of how to build them
repair them but you can build them and
do them yourself very maybe you know
what's funny is like we often make fun
of the great reset you will own nothing
and you'll be happy
you know have you've heard that right I
have yeah what if the you will owe
nothing is because everything's like
open source and available for you to
create your own you know what I mean
molecular printing like well let's think
about that I guess in that reality you
would own stuff you don't know what you
made I don't think that was meant as
nefarious as they said it when they
actually said it I think the the part of
it was you used to have a record
collection now you're going to be happy
with just you know you you search for a
song like you you just type it in and it
automatically starts playing for you
that type of thing but that's bad but
that coincide really bad the thing is
that statement and that trend of you
just having access to everything
immediately at the at your fingertips
whether it's an Uber for a car or music
just so happens to coincide with a
second separate Trend where every single
company is doing everything they can to
make things unrepairable because there's
more money to be made by buying a new
one it is nefarious to say you use that
record collection now you have it on
your phone because they can say you're a
naughty boy so we've banned you from
music forever you could you you know use
the record collection they could come
out and be like you're you're a jerk and
nobody likes you so you can can't come
to the record store anymore and they'd
be like well I got a big old pile of
Records right here at least I got those
now Spotify will just be like we're
gonna ban you like I'll tell you this
man lee Camp right you ever hear of Lee
Camp no he's like a lefty guy he works
for RT he had a podcast a personal
podcast it wasn't through RT and it got
deleted from Spotify because he worked
for RT that's redacted tonight right
redacted tonight was was deleted off of
uh YouTube he had another show on on
Spotify that got purged oh it's
different show for being for working for
a Russian Outlet or whatever and uh but
the point is that's that's a different
kind of suspension you could be booted
off you know iTunes and then you have no
music on iTunes and you say okay maybe
Spotify but if they all coordinate like
they did with Alex Jones it is a really
really bad thing for them to be like you
will own nothing and you will be happy
yeah you're happy until like in that
what was it Black Mirror where they
blocked someone in real life yeah they
just saw silhouette walking around I
think that what they meant with that
statement is that you're going to use
more services than own things I would
prefer to own things than have Services
myself that's my my preference but I
think that's that's a separate thing
then they can then what's happening now
which is everything that you buy winds
up becoming disposable but it but I I'm
glad that that statement exists and that
so many people are aggravated at that
statement because it's going to cause
people to be more sensitive to when you
buy something and there's you know
there's a five dollar chip in your three
thousand dollar MacBook that dies and
they tell the company that makes it not
to sell it to anybody do you actually
own what you buy if you cannot buy any
of the components necessary to repair it
because the company goes out of their
way to stop you from doing so like if I
go to intercil and I try to buy a chip
that I could have bought 10 years ago
I'm not allowed to they'll say we can
only sell to people who are on this
approved vendor list Renaissance
Electronics say we can only sell unless
approve vendor list same with Texas
Instruments if that's the case do you
actually own anything
I think it's uh why are you leasing it
are you leasing that tablet until it
dies if you own it technically you own
it you own an unrepairable piece of
Machinery I guess yeah because the life
cycles I love a lot of this stuff I mean
you know a lot of these devices will die
within a year or two but that's
intentional there's planned obsolescence
thing are they doing this on purpose I
think some of it is just the way like
the way people use things now but also
the fact that I mean if you plug it if
you plug a charger into a Macbook into
something weird with your Electrical uh
circuitry in your house or something
it'll just blow a cd3217 Chip it'll be
dead and you didn't do anything wrong
you don't even have to use a knockoff
charger for it to happen
this is like a very very common repair
we get it every single day really yeah
and there's something that I have to do
to get that chip that I can't say on
stream but it's but it's like it's it's
stupid that's nefarious not what you're
doing with that's nefarious that you
wouldn't be able to talk about it openly
I mean oh if it's a proprietary fix you
mean that you do no it's not even
proprietary fixed I can't say how we get
access to some of these things legally
it's not legal that's incredible but
it's it's really like it's just dumb
that things have to be that way like and
the thing is people will say well you're
only advocating for right to repair
because it helps your business it's like
no it's the opposite when you have 1
million YouTube subscribers you can say
you know oh man if only I had this chip
I could do this repair and I will get a
box that with no return address or
whatever with like a spool of chips and
say thank you for the YouTube videos
yeah the people that started someone rid
me of this priest and the priest has
just gone huh yeah the the people who
started where I did 10 years ago they
can't do that they're like when I when I
when I started 10 years ago they can't
do that they don't have the ability to
say something like that and just have
some contact reach out to them that
allows them to get access to all the
things that I can yeah like I'm doing
this for the people that start over did
because I want them to have a path to
get where I am now like I started doing
this when I had 200 in my bank account
one thousand dollars in credit card debt
and didn't you know I just dropped out
of college and I was able to start a
store and you know get 12 employees have
a decent quality of life and I want
everybody else to be able to do that but
that path is that bridge that I crossed
is slowly burning away behind me I agree
man completely yeah you know I want to
believe that if you if you just work
harder you dedicate yourself but uh I
mean looking at YouTube they're pulling
up the ladder behind us everybody
they're making it harder and harder for
people to have people of Merit aren't
going to be able to make it in I think
you know kind of just to do a quick
shift we're going to Super chats when it
comes to pulling up the ladder behind it
as far as it goes with media I think
when when YouTube started when the
internet was prominent meritocracy was
the law of the land if you made good
stuff that people wanted to see You'd
you would do well and meritocracy
doesn't mean good content people like
started posting boobies you know all
over YouTube and it worked really well
for their channels and made them huge
YouTube eventually started getting rid
of this and saying nah we should just
choose who wins and who loses that way
we have control of the situation so the
ladder's been pulled up behind everybody
that's why I recommend people now like
if you're going to start a channel
started on rumble or minds or mines do
some new network yeah you've got a real
chance at meritocracy on a new platform
that you want on YouTube are people
actually using them though that's the
biggest problem with new platforms they
are there like a bunch of people would
suggest that I use library and I I do
you know uh but but when I actually
opened up a library Channel nobody
watches it but uh Rumble if you know uh
Dan bongino gets got more views and has
more subscribers on Rumble than it in
YouTube that's interesting and uh and
that's one of the reasons probably an
investor in it because he was driving a
lot of that growth for sure but you know
he's he's he's got a what a nationally
syndicated radio show and podcast that
helped him build that up yeah but I'm
saying you know for you right now you
got you know 1.7 million subscribers or
whatever if you were to jump over to
rumble our minds you wouldn't have as
big of a platform but if someone right
now has nothing has no followers
whatsoever I'd say rumble you know in a
Edition yeah what you're saying about
the right to repair and access to open
source Machinery schematics and things
how do you feel about software code
like with proprietary networks for
instance Google uh YouTube something
like that I've never thought of the idea
of making of mandating that everything
be open source I like open source
software I like people when people make
it available but if you're going to make
a device that requires let's give an
example so there was a microwave
recently that I forget made by
Electrolux and because it was given a
software update that didn't work that
microwave now thinks that it's a steam
oven and it doesn't turn on because it
thinks it's a theme of it now while you
have a microwave that connects to Wi-Fi
is beyond me why anybody like they
perfected the microwave over everything
that you could have in a microwave like
40 years ago and they put a clock in a
microwave I think that was that was the
last update that you needed yes but um
if if something happens like that even
if you don't have access to the source
code should you be able to have access
to the ROM because what you need a
service technician to come out to your
home and fix that why can't you fix it
yourself because you don't have access
to the software so should that stuff be
made available for devices that require
it
well how about we go to super chats if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show if you really do like it's the
best way to help and don't forget to go
to timcast.com be a member one of the
members only segment coming up after the
show Let's uh let's read some of these
super chats we got archa magiris sancti
says here's a Jackson for Lewis and
Clinton Lewis is the man sub to his
channel that's my cat oh they're not the
politician Clinton let's just say wow
named for Bill name for socks that was
Bill's cat socks oh no but you named
your cat Clinton yeah for after Bill
Clinton or when I got him his name was
Thunder but they he was sexually
harassing all the other cats oh yeah
they put him in his own right they put
him in his own room with the stuffed
animals and he wouldn't stop humping the
animals
all right then the perfect good name I
love it all right BS production says
Lewis is the G of the right to repair
world I got my phone fixed at a small
repair shop because of his message right
on man thank you
all right Chloe small says trans women
here terrible tweet should the Babylon
be have been suspended for it no you
think every Joker comedian makes will be
hilarious same with satire websites I
stand with hate speech oh interesting
the interesting thing about that tweet
is that they when they say that they're
asking them to remove it rather than
removing itself Apple did this some
something similar to me six years ago
with one of my videos that had a
schematic in it they they didn't file a
dmca claim and they totally could have
because it's copyrighted and it says
literally in the schematic do not do
this do not share this and it's on it's
on my video but that I think part of the
reason they asked me to remove it is
because they didn't want the negative PR
from removing it so I told them I will I
have no problem removing 100 of my
YouTube content all I ask is you file a
dmca claim so that people don't think
that I did it so if Twitter asks you to
remove it then it doesn't look publicly
like Twitter deleted it for you versus
you were you just deleted it yourself
and I think that's why it's important to
not delete your own stuff if somebody
else wants you to the crazy thing about
it is
if it's against the rules why would
Twitter allow it to stay up
they're saying this broke the rules you
can't say anything until you get rid of
it because you will leave it's not a
popular rule like the rule that right
the rule that's all of my YouTube videos
could be dmca claimed by Apple in a day
and my channel would be gone that could
have happened six years ago but the
thing is it's a rule that doesn't have
popular support and it's and if they
were to actually enforce that then a
bunch of normal average everyday people
that large moderate middle that we were
talking about that don't actually do
anything would rise up and do something
and they don't want that to happen I
think it may maybe it's the same thing
with Twitter you know again with a tweet
like again I try I avoid misgendering
people because of why I I gained nothing
from it but I wouldn't ban it there was
a story about this uh this couple in the
UK I think they were protesting
McDonald's
and then McDonald's sued them in one and
the stock damage to McDonald's was
substantially worse than any of the
damage from the it was like two people
were protesting and heading out
pamphlets in front of McDonald's so they
sued him one and the pr below back was
massive saying this big Corporation went
after these like two random people
handing out pamphlets so I forgot what
the story like was called but since then
there's been like a corporate Doctrine
never to be uh Goliath going up against
David because it'll it'll hurt you more
and cost you more money it looks bad
even if the rule exists you you
shouldn't if the majority of people
would not agree with that rule existing
if it wasn't for invoked then it's best
to not invoke it yeah and just only
invoke it when it's not going to get you
into much trouble
yeah all right let's read this Murph
says Ian I agree with you 100 that text
is ruining our culture's Communications
would you put texting in that category
as well yeah it's kind of like we used
to mail each other letters um when we
had the post office back in the 1800s
and now then we've had a telephone and
then we invented video chat but I see
people reverting to mailing letters to
each other email you know digitally now
it's very disturbing yes I consider text
the exact same thing
so go back to video chats with your
friends well see the thing about text
messages though is that if you send
something over text that was
misconstrued you just press call and say
here I I meant this you know now with
Twitter you can tweet something and
people just either intentionally or
ignorantly don't understand what you
were saying the one thing I learned from
YouTube is that there are many ways for
other people to interpret what you say
and they have this so much work that has
to go into it that doesn't go into it
when I'm speaking to people that I know
well I think it's the internet in
general to be honest because
um mostly we were talking with uh and we
had Andrew Heaton on the show and he
mentioned that other people had talked
about oh Tim Poole oh man you know I've
seen clips of him and he's like yeah but
have you watched a show and they're like
no so the other day Ian made a made a
comment that I'm not going to repeat
because I'm not foolish enough to repeat
it but uh you were you were making a
hypo uh hypothetical argument and you
said someone might actually say have
their political opinion of you know I
believe X is good and then I was like
you shouldn't have said everyone laughed
because now it's going to happen is
someone who hates Ian will take a take
the clip of of that and then publish Ian
saying something and they'll attribute
the quote to him instead of it feels
like it's like a cop we're in a
constantive culture shock I remember
before the internet it would be very
rare to meet someone that I didn't agree
with about anything or that didn't agree
with me because I was from Cuyahoga
Falls and those are the people I knew
then now I would start to put my put my
oil onto the internet's water and you
just see these reactions the first from
the first moment it's never stopped I've
just become more used to it now but it's
still this constant culture shock every
day all these new people are responding
from God knows where on Earth what their
child like was like
I'm gonna read this because I'm confused
by it I'll just read it
um Pizza makes my belly hurt I'm sorry
to hear it says I seen Christopher Titus
this weekend he was talking about white
supremacists named dropped uh white
supremacist name dropped Kyle
rottenhouse Tucker Carlson and Hannity
people groaned and my group and others
left this was in Chicago people are
waking up wow interesting I saw uh
there's someone I knew a long time ago
and I looked him up on Facebook and like
the last post they have was like ranting
about white supremacy and all these
issues and I'm like man what happened to
you yeah that's weird it was fun to be
at work the day that the Kyle
writtenhouse verdict happened because I
have a workplace where everybody can
discuss it and there's no consequences
it's great like there were two people
that agreed with it and the rest
disagree with it but they all talked
about it and there was no consequence
nobody got fired no and it was just I I
found that day enjoyable it was crazy
how many people how many people cried
like one person that thought that he
should have gone to prison was like said
it and like there was no and the other
the people that thought that he he that
he did nothing wrong said it and there
was no con like none of them had to
worry about losing their jobs none of
them had to worry or care we you know we
admittedly there was 45 minutes where no
work got done that day because they were
all talking about it but it wasn't I
like the I know that there's a bunch of
companies or that could never happen and
I was proud to have a company culture
where that could happen and nobody like
hated each other because I believe there
is a greater than chance probability
that people who thought Kyle right now
should go to jail just didn't know
anything about the case or had limited
understanding of what happened it was
surprising how many people thought that
he was shooting at black people exactly
yep and then you know with this story it
was interesting because I know a bunch
of people who personally cried mostly
women to be honest like no disrespect
but a lot of women were like crying and
I was saying people even dudes tweeting
like I'm on the verge of tears man my
heart rate skyrocketed as the verse
about to be read because we all knew the
case and we all knew that he was
innocent and was defending himself and
that's how important it was that he was
found also shout out to a Social
Democratic political YouTuber that is on
the left Destiny who actually followed
the entire case stuck with the facts
regardless of people that were very
angry at him and followed facts and
logic over it I enjoy his channel for
that yeah for defending for he's he said
Kyle Rittenhouse was the clearest cut
clearest cut case of self-defense he'd
ever seen and so Twitter punished him
for it he always I'm sorry twitch yeah
he tries to avoid following a specific
bias as often as possible and I have a
lot of respect for him for doing that it
was fun yeah I love him yeah let's read
some more Super chats
all right
Archer meguria sancti says I love old
things because they're well made and I
can maintain them Lewis is fighting for
the massive cause of carrying the
philosophy forward to the 21st century
and and it should be
I I think the only people would oppose
that are massive corporations who like
planned obsolescence I think you know
the new group that's opposing it it
wasn't just them it was also people that
identify with the brand so a lot of
people nowadays they don't just I that
you can't just vote for somebody and say
this was the less crappy option you have
to identify all the way and defend every
single thing they do even when it's bad
or they buy a product and it's not I
bought this just because it does what I
want it has to be I love the company I
love the brand I will defend them all
the time and when they see somebody
attack apple or attack Tesla they don't
think I'm attacking Tesla because they
treated their customer poorly in this
instance they think I'm attacking Tesla
I'm attacking you personally and your
identity because you chose to buy it so
they re they have this reactionary way
of defending the company and becoming
Sims for them when it makes absolutely
no sense well I am outraged at Elon Musk
where's my starlink bro
they said it was going to be the end of
last year and now we're still sitting
waiting to get starlink seeing where you
are streaming out of I was very I was
very surprised that you could actually
stream out of this location when I saw
just how far out of the way you have to
go to come here yeah we had to get them
to actually lay like a mile of line it's
very exciting no like when I saw you had
the chickens that were like walking
around outside I figured they were just
carrying the packets yeah that's exactly
what's going on oh yeah yeah they carry
them manually yeah in order to get
internet out here we have we have so
they're I mean look we're we're not that
far away from DC so there is cable which
is not that fast then there's satellite
which is also not that fast but we've
we've used these as defaults and then we
actually had a company come and lay down
fiber they had to like actually dig and
you see those trucks outside and they're
laying it down for like a mile plus from
like the main Hub or whatever backhaul
it's very expensive people knew how
expensive it was to make sure like this
happened you know out here but uh it's
better than being in the big cities and
it all ends up being really really worth
it but once we get starlink it's good
you know could theoretically reduce our
costs dramatically I've heard that you
want to get multiple starlink bases if
possible so that you can have multiple
networks because one network won't be
enough
Jeremy the quartering was going through
this right now he actually just got
Starling set up really he's getting the
process of getting a set up yeah Elon
Elon that's not fair I tweeted at you
Tweet back darn it all right Howard says
starve the Beast Bitcoin equals love and
peace quit the dollar and starve the war
machine roll a 20. uh I'm a big fan of
Bitcoin myself who wants a 20-sided
did you roll a 20. no I rolled a six oh
the devil's number
let's grab some uh oh this is funny
seriously JK says New World Order is
trending on Twitter and the posts and
comments are pure gold yeah cause Biden
said yeah what the heck bro did you see
what he said yeah Joe Biden was like you
know he's like we created a liberal uh a
liberal world order or something and
soon we're gonna have a new world order
and it was like he's like every three or
four generations you know and there's
like I think he said I can't remember
exactly what he said but didn't he say
something like after World War II we
created a liberal economic order and
then you know soon we're gonna have a
new world order oh he laid it all out
yeah he's like okay you know you know
hey man much respect to the guys
learning it all out yeah maybe he's at
that age where he's lost his filter you
have to be very careful when you're when
you're a president and you speak in
vague terms because you never know how
people are going to take what you say
yeah like I'm not I'm not threatened by
a statement I'm not surprised or
anything just tell me more well my first
reaction rather than jump to something
would be tell me more I was I was deeply
offended when he had the nerve
to say true to understand yeah me too
yeah yeah
he said true pressure
huh that's what he said profound he said
I think he was trying to say true
International cooperation cooperation
Under Pressure I just all got merged
into one turn it on a shot of pressure
and also it didn't fall through with
that as we can see the Ukraine Biden
shrewin oh there it is international
shooting on a shot without pressure
let's see here we go is it gonna play
I'll be worse when I'm 70. I'll need an
effective strategy to mobilize true and
international over depression how late
it affect the strategy to mobilize true
and international for depression how
late it affect the strategy to mobilize
true and international pressure
and there's an extra inner that I'm
missing an international pressure 50
years from now I'm probably gonna sound
worse no he also he also said battle
Cafe
keep meditating was it cath or calf calf
better calf care yeah I have no idea
what he was trying to say there better
Better Health Care oh yeah better health
care it's a court manto a word it's okay
support man too you're allowed well I
was deeply offended that was a slur oh
yeah that's that yeah to to podcast to
to um beanie wearing podcasters that's
you know that's yeah it's like our um
yeah that's like cool
all right let's read some more
Joseph Henson says question to get Lewis
going do you really own a thing if you
aren't allowed to do what you want with
it within reason I don't think you do I
think the definition is gonna have to be
updated at some point
if that's a good point what is that
water
it's metal
do you own it I think I do but what if I
said you can't open it and pour the
water on the ground
is that not within reasons no literally
I mean it's saying it's not within
reason so I don't think that's within
reason right
yeah and that's the perspective that
when I speak to more right-wing people
about it who tend to be against any sort
of legislation whatsoever because that
would be government doing something it's
I mean what is the government's job like
what was it there for the fun one of the
ideas was to protect property rights and
if you don't have property rights if you
can't like one instance one example if
uh if you import something that's
counterfeit you're not allowed to do
that fine but if somebody takes apart an
iPhone in China and all the parts of
Apple logos and they bought it at an
Apple store in China and then it gets
shipped to Florida if it goes to a
certain Customs or if it goes to a
certain custom sport just be anything
with an Apple logo just gets tossed out
so you could literally have an iPhone
that somebody bought in China they sent
all the individual parts and flex cables
over and that could get confiscated that
that's a way of keeping you from fixing
your stuff wow so I mean one of the
government's jobs even from a small
government conservative perspective is
it's there to protect property rights
and part of your ability to protect
property rights is to protect your
ability to fix things I don't think that
any of the laws that one of the things I
liked about Andrew Yang's campaign is he
said that every time we come up with a
new piece of legislation we are going to
write down here's why we're doing this
here's the problem we're looking to
solve so you know the interpretation of
it and I think I strongly believe when
they came up with all the all the laws
that we have now regarding Customs
intellectual property copyright patents
none of that was intended to keep you
from being able to fix what you own and
I think that if they did know that it
was ever going to be used that way 50 or
90 or 200 years later that there would
have been something written in there to
ensure that you have the ability to fix
what you own business because I mean
even John Deere they were advertising in
the 30s and 40s and 50s in their own
literature this is how easy it is to fix
our product that was the primary
advertising point of a lot of their own
you ever hear the story about uh public
drinking in New York
when they when they first passed the
bill the idea was that they wanted to
stop drunkards from Milling about and
causing problems and so there's a quote
it could be apocryphal but this
politician said or a judge was like
never let never let it be misconstrued
that this bill would bar a construction
worker from enjoying a beer with his
lunch quite literally that's what it
does if you if you were in New York City
and you have an open drink they're going
to give you a ticket for it especially
depending on where you are I guess if
you're like drinking wine in Central
Park you can get away with it you can
generate more Revenue to make the ticket
than it does to not generate the things
exactly yeah you see so they found
ultimately they were like we'll make
money enforcing the law New York really
likes Revenue
yeah they sure do I've learned that
lesson the hard way
all right let's get some more what do we
have here
Jess Bischoff says my name is Patrick
Gibson I thought your name was Jess
Bishop I beat Mike Phelps three times
and uh until we were 13. do you have any
clue of the world records I would have
if I competed against biological females
it's so wrong I've known Mike Phelps
since we were both five years old if he
chose to do this it would be awful
but it says Jess Bischoff is Pat Gibson
just using Jess's account no no is that
a pen name that's Michael Phelps the
swimmer by the way yeah Mary M says
Twitter just suspended that second
placed woman swimmer due to her tweet
about Leah happy
um actually Recca was not second she was
17th and that Twitter account was
reportedly not really her and that's why
it was suspended
um additionally I will state this again
for those that may have missed their
Miss dealer's segment earlier segment
the woman who came in 16th Place who's
in the finals did not complain the woman
who came in 18th Place who would not
have placed in finals with or without
Leah did not complain it's the one woman
who did compete only after losing and
missing it by one petition say that
person shouldn't be in this race I'm
getting a feeling that people encouraged
her to complain it just feels like that
I don't know why I encourage all of them
to complain if they're genuinely unhappy
about but they don't care look like
don't wait until after you lose to
complain it's the same thing how the
Republicans started arguing about the
election stuff after the election like
that's not true cure it beforehand if
you're going to do something that's not
true the lawsuits were being filed they
had years before I mean they did it in
the months leading up but they had years
to prep for that kind of thing well and
truth be told the Republicans actually
passed a bunch of the laws that they end
up getting mad about in the end whoops
all right chaos a tournament says
Freedom trucker here the only coverage
we get is from ish spreaders the
propaganda is unreal they don't want us
in their backyard I think he he yeah the
truckers have been going around uh the
DC area for some time now right yeah
they have yeah right on
oh this is good news RB says
congratulations to Indiana for becoming
the 24th constitutional carry statement
that's two states in three weeks Ohio
and then Indiana yeah
yeah just think once we have nationwide
constitutional carry you can like cross
state lines with a weapon it's awesome
yeah not right now though what do you
think about constitutional carry I
support the Second Amendment I'm fine
all right it's just in my state the Old
State they only allow it for criminals
I really have never had a problem with
people having a gun yeah I think people
should have guns it's it's we I I don't
know how that would work in New York
because you'd be introducing it
everybody in New York City is vibrating
with some sort of anxiety or aggravation
and it's only when I come down from New
Hampshire to like you know visit the
store and walk around a bit that I
realize the difference and it's just how
would reintroducing guns to 8.5 million
people in this tiny little space the
size of Knoxville Tennessee be like
compared to areas where they're already
accustomed to the culture you know in
Texas they're accustomed to it in
Tennessee they're accustomed to it New
Hampshire Florida they are New York that
would be interesting I'm not sure how
that would go I think I think there's a
problem with uh the the more dense a
population area becomes the the more
rights get stripped away because
everyone's anxious and on edge and kind
of points in Florida you know they
respect the Second Amendment and I love
traveling to Florida in New Hampshire
they have a very high ownership of
machine gun owners per capita and I have
no problem going to New Hampshire I I'm
not threatened by it at all if you said
that everybody in New York City could
have a gun tomorrow I don't know if I'd
love it yeah I don't know I don't know
if I want to be there for the culture
shock period yeah I think the issue is
that people are extremely tightly wound
into places like this yes not not to
mention
um there's a lot of arrogance a lot of
arrogance at a place like New York so
you'd have a lot of people thinking like
oh I know what I'm doing I don't need to
take a class or get training or any
safety or anything like that and then
they'd you know you'd have problems but
uh you know my ultimately my position is
Second Amendment exists if you want to
change it you better amend the
Constitution if you can't people can
have their guns
although we had a conversation with even
Luke
you know Luke said this I was we were
talking about owning guns in like a
building and I was saying like someone
brought this up like what if you had a
308 rifle in like an apartment in New
York City and someone broke in and you
fired at him and it went through Luke
said this is Luke if we had changed I
want to make sure everybody knows Luke
he was like maybe we don't allow those
kind of bullets and I was like
oh snap that's not a real Second
Amendment then well he was like well
okay no I think he admitted he was right
a bullet that was not going to go
through the wall of a crappy New York
City apartment is probably going to be a
Nerf dart yeah
I mean I don't know like your paintball
gun like penetrates four walls and
you're like
there's no paint yeah they just it gets
like lodged in the fourth you know
drywall
all right
TJ says and from pronouncing it right
Ian is right I see all human interaction
as manipulation everything someone does
has an impact in their world regardless
of size the question is where does where
does one will end and where does one end
and uh will another begin
and when are you are you aware that you
are manipulating other people you got to
be able to keep you keep well I'll tell
you here's my issue if you are aware
that what you do is manipulating someone
you're considered wrong yeah it's
considered bad no if you if you're
accidentally doing so I'll play this way
let's say you're a guy I I thought about
this when I used to work for nonprofits
there were people who naturally had the
Gift of Gab and could get people to sign
up for nonprofits like that they didn't
need to be trained or learn any practice
they just walk up to someone say all the
right things and they would nail it
there were other people who were like I
need to figure out how they're doing
that and they would they would map it
out and then go through a strategy of
manipulating someone into doing it
mapping it out was considered wrong
because you're manipulating them but
just naturally being good at it is
considered fine and I'm like I don't
know I think they're both fine I guess
if you know how to communicate to
someone and get them to do something
whether you learned it or not it's fine
if you have good intentions and if
you're not trying to harm them you want
to help them I mean the problem is if
you want to help someone you you turn
them in the wrong direction that you
know so you gotta be careful but just be
aware that everything you say to a
person is manipulating them their
thoughts everything I really like the uh
you do you and I'll do me because when
you end up screwing up I don't want to
be responsible for it that's like you
know a big key part of like my
libertarian ethos it's like if I don't
assert authority over you to do
something and then you get hurt like
that was your choice and your fault and
I am not responsible for your decisions
now there's certain circumstances where
I have to assert authority over someone
they have to do this and then I'm
responsible for and boy do I not like
that yeah welcome to fatherhood
welcome to running a business yeah
that's you have an employee who does
something and then it's like it's your
company and it's like
yeah all right
all right Howard says yep bye bye as the
Petro dollar goes BTC love you know be
as as goes BTC equals love peace if you
want to uh if you want Ripple
centralized Ledger I don't know what
that means do you get into crypto Lewis
no I said so much of it just seems like
a consensual Ponzi scheme to me like the
US dollar kind of a little bit Yeah but
uh that's the power of Bitcoin is it's
decentralized and there's no federal
Bitcoin Reserve so as much as the dollar
is a Ponzi scheme where they just keep
printing more money and propping the
system up Bitcoin is kind of inverted no
no centralized control and it's you know
there's only a fun amount that can exist
so then entropy will actually remove
coins over a long period of time uh
generally increasing their value so long
as people use them for trade so I'm a
big fan I like the utility tokens that
actually do something I can understand I
understand people that want to own land
houses or let's say companies that do
something it's hard for me to understand
people wanting to go from fiat currency
to bitcoin because like I understand
owning something that produces something
or owning something that has and in
fundamental intrinsic value like you can
live in this this company produces oil
this company produces food this land
produces something what if you only have
like 500 bucks what what can you invest
in a hard asset to help protect you from
um
pick one I screw up I'm not telling
anybody to go do it but um gold silver
Bitcoin our our Hijos I look at the
price of silver and gold and I don't see
them tracking very well so I think they
are still decent to have because you
want Alternatives but Bitcoin has has
been remarkable for people trying to
store and protect their value if you
invested in Bitcoin right at the start
of the pandemic Bitcoin was around 4 500
uh five thousand dollars you did well if
you invested once anybody fomo in when
it was 60k then you're like
it's at 40 right now yeah so if you if
you bought it at the start of the
pandemic then you're very you're doing
very well yes and it was a lot of people
who saw like hey right now there's a
crisis they're going to print money it's
going to be a disaster currency is going
to go wild you need to put something
somewhere the thing about Bitcoin is the
average person what can they buy as a
hard asset with only maybe 50 bucks or
100 bucks you're screwed nothing Bitcoin
you can buy Bitcoin but is that a hard
asset yes well I mean you can call it
liquid but Bitcoin is an asset where you
get your you get value out of the dollar
and then Bitcoin is only going to go up
granted Bitcoin fluctuates I think it's
just based on speculation Bitcoin going
on it's weird because I agree with much
of what Peter Schiff says
philosophically even though he's been
110 wrong on price every single time
yeah but when it comes to price it's
just his mutual funds are almost perform
as badly as his uh take on bitcoin has
when it comes to price but from a
philosophical perspective or you know
what is this based on I agree with them
you don't know why bitcoin's price goes
up it's predictable
so there's there's things called
happenings where the I'm going to
probably going to butcher this but the
general idea is like the the the amount
of Bitcoin you get as a reward for
mining a block gets cut in half or
something of that effect and so that
means if you're spending x amount of
dollars and electricity to mine a
Bitcoin and then the Bitcoins all get
half by reward now it's basically saying
it's twice as much electricity to
generate one Bitcoin so it's going to
force the price to go up so it's
actually you can see the Ripples and
it's it's all it's all entirely
predictable because it's predictable you
need only confidence in it and because
there is substantial confidence in
institutional investment in it people
are basically like Bitcoin can only go
the last happening was May 11 2020 right
after the pandemic I wonder if that's
part of why boom it goes up so miners
are generating all this Bitcoin and
they're spending electricity to make it
they're spending money on electricity to
get it they like to use Renewables
because then you can it's cheaper for
you in the long run but then you hold
the Bitcoin and then what happens is
there's like a happening then there's a
big sell-off from all the miners which
causes a price fluctuation and then like
a spike happens because now the amount
of energy to produce Bitcoin is going up
and they're supplying demand I didn't
know that I learned something well I'm
probably butchering it I should read
nothing wrong because I know I learned
something but uh much of this much of
the the price increases can be like are
rather predictable because of the flock
because of the code you can see it's
open source but uh again ask somebody
who probably knows that you know way
more generally speaking though my view
of it is you know uh what was it
November of like 2019 we had bill here
and he was like by ethereum and I was
like okay so I bought a bunch of Bitcoin
and a bunch of ethereum and then took
off the pandemic happened and uh I have
never in 10 years regretted buying
Bitcoin I have regretted every single
time I sold it so yeah yep but right now
my investment in Bitcoin is substantial
like uh not like I have a lot of Bitcoin
but that I invested a little bit like
like eight years ago and now it's just
like I have no reason to sell it because
like it's just even if it went if it
went down 80 you're still ahead yeah
like I bought in at like a grand so
you're ahead regardless so I'm like not
worried about it I like how you said
that utility is key like with a with a
phone if you're gonna invest in
something you want utility out of it
like a house something you can utilize
that some cryptos have a they're called
utility tokens that actually do
something like if you go to minds.com
you spend one Minds token you can get a
thousand views so it's like it's like
advertising so there's a utility in the
token it's not just a not just a piece
of paper you know so I I really think
that the future of utility in in crypto
is gonna be like smart contracts and
being able to like cut out the middleman
that's the guy who's like getting the
the paycheck and then making sure the
button gets flipped it's just gonna the
paycheck's gonna make the button flip
for you and those cryptos are going to
become very valuable chain link things
like that let's read one more here the
wrong writer says drunk Super Chat Show
idea Ian should review fast food I miss
you Ian love you oh I used to love Taco
Bell and I don't mean it like it was
good for me love it it's delicious it
would be uh it would be hilarious if
there was a YouTube show of Ian
reviewing fast food but that would mean
Ian eating eating fast food every day
that's what's that guy The Machinist
didn't he lose all that weight for The
Machinist oh Christian Bale yeah that
was so gross but there's already uh food
that few Food review guy what's his name
review bro
the one is that memory is like my my uh
my what is it what does he say
something like my dissatisfaction isn't
oh yeah what is that one and my day is
ruined yeah yeah Epic Meal my
disappointment Epic Meal Time they did
it they took unhealthy food and would
Gorge and man that that show burned out
I don't know if you can if I could do
that for very long it's just so gross
like putting plastic in your stomach
yeah I don't know about that all right
everybody smash that like button if you
have not subscribed to this channel
share the show with your friends we're
gonna go over to timcast.com to record
that members only segment which should
be up at around 11 p.m so you don't want
to miss it those are always fun and
unfamily friendly you can follow the
show at timcast IRL everywhere except
Tick Tock who banned us and you can
follow me at timcast Lewis you want to
shout out any anything I don't have
anything in mind social media got a
Twitter or uh YouTube YouTube channel
Rossman group and that's about it nice
okay right on help people fix things and
get people involved that's how you get
that's how you change the world what's
the best way for people to get involved
uh if they know how to fix something and
they know somebody that needs something
fixed to get them involved and get them
to see how they can save money and get
them to have that little kick adult me
when something works again like you know
it's not about watch watching my YouTube
videos or giving money to my non-profit
it's about getting as many people as
humanly possible to feel that kick a
dope me when something works again and
when they save some money because then
they'll naturally support it and then
they'll see through slander from
companies from politics politicians from
lobbyists and anybody else yeah all
right well hey I'm Ian Crossland uh
check that Ian crossland.net I'll see
you guys later
quote from that review show is my
disappointment is immeasurable and my
day is ruined so if you want to Ian
review stuff no I'm just kidding we're
not gonna make you in review fast food
although that would be hilarious if
you've never seen the dude actually say
it it's one of the best videos ever I
need to watch that because it's like a
dead band he's just like he's not very
enthused or like excitable he's just
totally flat yeah I love it I had to
look it up because I was really curious
what the full quote was anyway you guys
can follow me on Twitter and minds.com
at sour patchlitz we will see you all
over at timcast.com in about an hour
thanks for hanging out bye guys